Hello, everybody.
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
Welcome, welcome, welcome in.
And welcome back to Double Make Cry.
Make Cry.
Woo-hoo!
Thank you guys for the super jobs.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
One second.
I think my setup is weird.
Hold on.
That was better.
I think I'm stupid.
I think last week, last time I played this, I was like, oh, yeah, I'm going to endurance the rest of this.
This game.
And then I'm like, looking out, I'm like, I'm only on mission 8 out of 20.
I have high lofty goals.
I have big goals.
And big, it's a big eyes, small stomach.
But, I do want to finish it tomorrow.
So, we'll do double, double, double, double, double, make cry.
So, I was just, um, also, I was also like, oh, I could probably endurance this game for a long time.
But, as you can see, I'm wearing glasses today.
And that's because, because of that, I slept in my spirit lenses, aka contacts.
And my glasses, especially when I wear headphones, they hurt my head.
They usually hurt my head anyway, because my head is too big and my glasses are too small.
I have sensitive, I have like a baby cranium.
Very soft.
And so, I slept in my contacts, and now I have to wear my glasses all day.
And, and they hurt with my headphones, so.
Hmm, yes.
Did you get your gorb?
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh, thank you for asking.
Because I was like, oh, I'm gonna do daily logins, so that I can get gorbs every day.
Did I do that?
No.
Did I remember yesterday?
Yes, I did.
And then, I opened up today, and I think, I don't know what time it's on to get the dailies.
You know, but, speaking of dailies, while I'm talking, I'm gonna do my Blue Archive ones.
Um, but, uh, but it didn't give me one for today, so.
They make headphones for glasses wearers.
Yeah, but I don't, I don't like wearing my glasses, because they hurt my head, regardless of if I have headphones or not.
So, I'm not gonna buy headphones just for that.
Bad thing about having such a huge brain and anime eyes.
I know, my brain is way too big.
I'm so wise.
New glasses?
Yeah, I thought about it.
Did you get your glasses resized to be more comfy?
No.
I could have.
Minto-sensei!
Ohayou gozaimasu!
That's what she says.
Wait.
Oh, she says oka iri nasai.
Sorry, I couldn't catch her say the Minto-sensei.
Soft-serve Minto-cranium.
No, I thought about going to the eye doctor, which I probably need to do again, though.
Hi, doc!
To, um, what's the word?
Uh, get them, get the new prescription, maybe.
I don't think I know.
Just the eye exam, right?
Amy, that was my birthday!
Would you believe I've never once had a VTuber sing happy birthday to me?
Since you aren't singing now, would you instead accept one sincere compliment?
Without fighting back too much.
Also, that was my controller disconnecting.
Don't worry about it.
A compliment?
Also Murphy, happy birthday!
I could sing.
I'd rather sing.
I'd rather sing, I'm not gonna lie.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Murphy.
I'm okay.
Don't melt your eyes.
I'm not.
Also, my voice is a little worse than usual today.
So, we'll just, I'll just play until I feel like it.
I think I'll be okay.
I think it'll be fine.
I think it's because I had some milk earlier.
And my voice is a little...
icky.
Icky grossness.
But also, I'm eating cough drop right now, so...
It's my birthday today, Minto.
Could you do a spoken word jazz birthday song?
I'm not doing compliments.
McMac, happy birthday!
It's also, I'm not giving compliments, you guys.
It says, Murphy said, would you accept a compliment?
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to, I don't want to accept anything.
All I do is accept my fate.
What's a jazz karaoke, or not karaoke, jazz birthday song?
I don't even, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
How do I jazz birthday song?
That just sounds like a spoken word jazz.
It's like a beat poem.
Uh, uh, oh!
Uh, no, I don't get it.
Wait, huh?
Miss Fizz, shut up.
What is spoken jazz?
You've done spoken jazz already.
I have?
What is it?
I don't know.
How do you spoken jazz?
Jazz with speaking voice.
Skibbidi, skibbidi, bap badeb.
Skibb...
Uh, beep beep, ba ba ba.
Skip, skibbidi, ba booba.
Happy birthday.
Big Mac.
Happy birthday to everybody.
Happy birthday... I think I did it right.
I think that's a happy... that's a birthday... that's a birthday song, probably.
Of... of the... of the... of the... spoken jazz variety.
Perfect!
Oh, yeah, baby!
And...
Oh my gosh!
Oh, they're already hurting my head!
Ooh!
Hold on.
I'm taking out my glasses.
Maybe I can try and find my... um... my earbuds instead.
Oh... One second!
One second!
I'll check this drawer!
Negative.
I think they're in my backpack.
Where's my backpack?
Ah... Oh... I have air... I have earbuds instead of... instead.
Oh.
sobre... headphones.
Hmm... Go in the Wendy's?
I... I want a... I want... I want... I want a... a... uh... baked potato.
And I want... um... I want... I want... I want... uh... with sour cream.
And I want... uh... four-piece chicken nuggets... sweet and sour... nuggets.
Please!
As someone with glasses and headphones, I can relate.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Let me go find my backpack.
I think I know where it is.
Oh my god.
Murphy.
No!
Will you let yourself be proud of it sometime?
I'm escaping.
I'm escaping to go find my backpack.
So what I have... is a big bag that's filled with other bags.
Because I have so many bags.
I think... is it in this backpack?
Oh wait.
That's candy.
No.
It's not in that one.
Hold on.
My backpack isn't in here!
Uh oh.
I just made a mess for no reason.
I gotta put my bag... bags back.
My bags back in my bag.
For those who don't know what's going on, I'm looking for my ear... my ear buds.
Can you guys hear my bag?
And then my purse.
And I'll just zip that up later.
Hold on.
I think I know where it is.
Okay.
Oh no!
It's stuck!
Why is it stuck?
Okay.
I found my backpack.
Now I dig through here.
That's a deodorant.
That's lotion.
That's more lotion.
Oh!
There's my watch.
That's a...
That's not the wrong headphones.
Nah.
My watch has been found.
That's candy.
Oh no!
Is it not in here either?
No way.
Wait.
Maybe it's in this little pouch that I keep inside my bag.
It is!
I found my ear buds.
Did
you hear that?
It was... it was velcro ASMR.
Okay.
Now I won't be dying.
Even though I'm already dead.
Ear buds discovered.
Okay.
Yeah.
I somehow have stashes of candy.
I don't know why.
I don't...
They're like hard candy.
I don't even like hard candy.
I don't know why they exist.
Okay.
Dying to what?
Oh wow.
It sounds so weird.
Um...
Dying to...
My headphones.
Because I'm wearing my glasses today.
And they put too much pressure on my face.
You knew.
Thank you so much for the time gifted.
Thank you.
All right.
That was a journey.
And you know what will also be a journey is...
Today's stream.
Why did I sound...
Okay.
Whatever.
Shady!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the time gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Happy birthday.
All righty, guys.
Are we ready to continue?
I got to connect my controller again.
Boop.
Look.
Why does it sound like it's disconnecting...
When it's connecting?
You're so confusing.
All right.
Continue.
Devil may cry.
Judging my...
I can't read anything.
Game is too fast.
Did we watch this?
Oh.
Guess there's no point thinking about it.
Yes, we did.
That's okay.
We'll watch it again.
Nico is so cute.
Ew.
Flirting with me?
Knock it off.
Get in the car.
Get...
How do you...
Get in the car.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I think I've kind of finally put what she...
Who she reminds me of.
And I think it's K-Sun.
She reminds me of K-Sun.
Like in looks and also like...
Personality.
She's got the accent and everything.
She's so much like her.
I already like bags.
So put a small bag and a bag and a bigger bag.
Inside a larger bag.
Inside another bag.
Inside a bag.
So we're not doing a Vito compliment.
Now I can't unsee it.
Oh my god.
Lady.
Hi, lady.
Alright.
I lost...
I lost a lot of irons last time.
I think.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Let's see.
Do I have any?
I might be able to buy some.
Oh, we have some more we can add in there.
Perfect.
Pilter, skelter.
Minto condiments.
A little bit of ketchup.
A little bit of...
Oh my gosh.
Remember how they used to make like purple ketchup?
They make...
Wait.
They made a green ketchup.
No?
They'll make a...
They'll make a mint ketchup.
That lady smell.
What?
Yeah.
A long time ago.
They were like...
Look at this kooky, wacky ketchup.
And it was purple.
And then...
Oh, they made the Shrek ketchup for...
Or...
The green ketchup was for Shrek.
Oh, I didn't realize.
But yeah.
So then they made a green ketchup.
Turn...
Wait.
It was bad for you?
So like pretty potties.
Oh, probably.
Probably, probably.
Alright, let's jump into the void real quick for me to just...
Just...
Get a little bit, you know.
I'm a bag playing a bag disguised as...
Another bag.
Wait, which one is it?
There we go.
Where...
Was it?
This one?
Hold on.
Wait.
No, no, no.
Exit real quick.
I wanna...
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Let me see my skill list real quick.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, this is blue rose.
Hold on.
Red queen.
Why, why, why, why, why?
Then why?
Then the...
Okay, so out on the ground.
Okay, let me see.
No, I'm not doing it well.
There we go.
It's such a long pause.
I can't ever remember.
Oh, I don't know why I did that.
Oh,
the X seed.
Oh, what am I using now?
Oh, Gerbera.
I don't know.
Wait.
Hold on.
And then this one does...
Oh, ragtime.
Ragtime does, like, the little balls.
And then you can make all of time stop.
Yeah, yeah.
What was it to get rid of a...
It was, um...
Elf?
Yeah.
Punchline.
This one is...
Then we can call it back.
Okay.
Punchline.
I think I'm good.
I think I'm okay.
I'll get...
I'll get back into it, probably.
It's that water, though.
Yeah, the rocket punch.
Hmm.
I think I'm okay for now.
What was my...
Let's see.
What would we have?
Oh, yeah.
Gerbera.
I'm gonna switch.
Let's switch it so that...
Let's switch these.
We'll have a punchline.
Actually...
I'm gonna have a helter-skelter, maybe.
Wait, I don't know.
He has a doorknob arm.
Ah.
Maybe I should just buy some.
Oh.
Wait.
What did Tomboy do again?
Oh, the bustle...
They're so expensive.
Do they also get more expen...
Wait, Rawhide.
Have I tried this one yet?
Always rev.
That's right.
Buy in bulk.
Buy one of each.
Ah.
Rawhide is the whip.
Oh.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Um.
Is it?
Is the...
Do these...
So if I buy one, will it, like, increase the price for the next time I buy it?
Yeah, there will be arms in the level.
You know what?
Because of that, we'll...
Uh.
We'll get rid of...
We'll keep some of these at home.
Wait, go back.
How do I remove you?
Remove.
There we go.
I'm even gonna remove ragtime because...
I don't feel like I know how to use it well enough.
No?
Oh, okay.
Wait.
No.
Maybe...
I'm like, we could buy Tomboy or Rawhide.
Oh.
Tomboy is kind of nice to have.
You can get them for free, though.
We'll see what's in the level.
We'll just see what's in the level and see what...
see what we can grab.
For now, I have three.
All right.
Mission eight.
I think someone said this.
Or people were saying that this mission is a little...
a little...
uh...
longer.
So, let's get it out.
I just want to start it.
Yeah, yeah.
It doesn't even look like we're in the city anymore.
Not that that was ever an option.
Yeah.
Time for some payback.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Just you wait, you big bastard.
I'll drag you all the way down here.
I know this is where we came from, but...
Nothing?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
The city is totally...
Nothing?
I can't tell what...
Oh, there's some...
roar bees there.
Noice.
Onwards.
The city has become a tree.
Oh.
What is that?
What the hell?
This is bad.
Noice.
Yeah.
Doesn't look any worse than...
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
This does look pretty bad, actually.
Holy cow.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I was going to say, it doesn't look...
Any worse than before, I suppose, but...
Yeah.
It's not looking great for our little...
For our little city.
It's not looking...
Not looking...
Too hot.
Just Florida?
Oh, my God.
Everything's pulsing.
Whoa.
Okay.
Who?
Where?
Whomst?
Oh, there they are.
Come here.
Oh, he's already dead.
Uh, hold on.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
There we are.
What if we kiss into the giant...
Undulating, veiny, demon tree heart?
Wow.
Any takers?
Any...
What the?
The music is freaky.
Any takers?
Making sure I don't miss anything.
If I miss something...
Um, you can say...
Go back.
Me to hole.
Oh, this looks like a...
Big ol' area for...
Battle.
Goal.
Oy.
Come here.
Oh, my God.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Ow.
Down, down, down, down, down.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Just kill it.
Just kill it till it's dead.
Owww, John.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Come in.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Come in.
Told you you were in Florida, with the gators.
We got them gators.
Yeah, they never stood a chance.
So true, Nero.
He believes in me.
Why is this light lit up?
Makes me want to explore.
It makes me want to explore.
No.
This looks like a big old area for battle the whole game.
Well, oh, there's something sparkly there.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh no.
What is?
The lava?
Oh, nice.
We got a new Gerbera.
We'll take it.
Uh.
Oh.
I guess that's your... Run.
No, bus!
Please!
Mr... Mr. Driver, please!
I'm gonna miss my stop.
Oh my god.
My depth perception strikes again.
Oh my depth perception.
Oh, wait.
Can you do another one?
Can you do another evil hand in the lava?
Please.
I missed the previous evil hand in the lava.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Alrighty.
Wait, what's on... We're going to the other side, but what's on this side?
Oh my god.
It pays to be curious.
Literally.
Okay.
La-la-la-la-la-la-bla!
Ta-ta-ta-ta-gain!
Would be fun to come up with a story of...
...why there are loads of robotic arms just lying around.
I believe that it's just Niko kind of like...
...chucking them.
You know?
Just to, you know, she's... She's just like... And... Just kind of throws him out into the... Wow, there's a lot of warb... Things here.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I grab my... I grab arms here, right?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, no, I gotta... But where's it taking me?
The shootin' yet.
Oh, there's one up there.
Wait.
We got it.
We got it, boys.
No worries.
No worries here.
Do you think, um...
Do you think this is gonna cause the neighborhood market to go down?
The housing, you know... Oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh, these guys again.
Don't get me.
Don't strike me.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I like that they give you health.
It's pretty...
Pretty special.
In this economy...
Bloodstreams.
I was just about to say, what the heck is that?
These conduits snake throughout the...
Cliffoth.
Transporting blood gathered in the human world.
Offer yourself to the flow.
And it will carry you deep into the tree.
But be warned.
There's no turning back once ye enter.
Where does this go?
Yeah, that's a great question.
Okay.
Wait.
That's totally something...
No?
Never mind.
It's totally nothing.
Did I get everything then?
I think we're good, right?
One with the flow.
Oh, my God.
Oh, well.
Whoa.
Go behind it.
Something behind.
Thank you, guys.
All right.
Thank you, thank you.
Perfect.
Howdy doody.
We're entering the tree.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I think it tastes like a pomegranate or something.
Holy cow.
Badass.
Badass dread.
Cool.
That was really...
That was kind of sickening.
That was so nasty.
I don't think I ever want to go through that.
I see.
I think I see an arm.
Wait, but I really like...
I actually really like rawhide.
Ra...
Hide.
Punch down.
So many arms.
I don't think there's any warbs.
We can turn it up.
Oh.
Nice.
Wait, I want to...
There we go.
Yeah.
Wait.
No.
Take it.
Oh, there's more of them.
Oh, no.
It's this guy.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
What's happening?
Aaaaaah!
Okay.
Damn.
All the way down.
Too heavy, huh?
You guys are too fat!
No!
You're too fat!
What the hell is that?
I
don't like that thing.
I don't want that thing.
I don't want that thing around me.
I don't want that thing...
I'm getting away from it.
I'm getting these guys first.
Oh my god.
Just like Mata.
Yeah, actually.
Does feel pretty... reminiscent of her, huh?
There we go.
Okay, now we can fight it.
Okay.
Go arm, go!
So funny.
It's kind of slow, actually.
It's actually not even...
I'm just attacking its butt.
Dodge!
No!
Oh no.
Oh.
There we go.
Wait, oh.
I didn't even get a little bit.
Oh my god, please!
There we go.
Attack its supple behind.
Well, we made it.
With minimal... minimal damage.
I think we're okay.
And there's another arm for us.
After we just lost ours.
How kind of them.
Overture.
Nice.
It was a good thing I didn't bring any more arms.
I don't know.
Are these people?
Oops.
Don't attack the bakery!
That's the best part, though.
Right now.
Yeah.
I killed them?
Oh yeah.
It's totally my fault.
It's totally my doing.
Uh...
Oh wait.
I'm so stupid.
I forgot to...
I forgot to lock on.
There we go.
Whee!
Yeah.
It's totally my doing that they're in this predicament.
I guess so.
Don't miss!
Wait, I saw some...
I saw some over here.
Wait, can I get the...
Oh.
Nice!
I feel like saving this.
Just in case I need it.
Wait, what are these?
Nothing?
They look so cool, though.
Okay, maybe I'm not.
Okay.
I thought we were about to be ambushed, though.
I'll just take it, then.
Okay.
Orbs.
Oh, here we go.
While riding punchline, you can press X to attack.
You need to go in the air while airborne with the left stick direction.
What?
Boss?
A boss fight?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
What?
Oh, I- Sorry, I just- what?
Yeah!
What?
Balfelmet!
Oh my god.
What are you, Pokemon?
Come here.
Can I grab you over here?
You're not so bad.
You're not so tough.
Oh, wait.
You really weren't.
Uh-oh.
Are there going to be three more of you?
Jump, jump, jump away.
Oh, my God.
And another one of you.
You sneaky.
Stay away from me.
Where are you guys?
Trying to do the...
There we go.
Oh, oh, gosh.
Ew, you...
Nice parry.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Take him down.
That guy doesn't do so well against guns, I think.
Music toco.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Jar Jar Binks went to the dark side.
Jar Jar Binks.
That guy.
Okay.
That wasn't so bad.
Oh.
Another...
Another elevator.
Let's check behind it.
Where's he going to take me now?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
What is this?
Sneaky!
Sneaky...
Darth Jar Jar.
A little pit.
This...
These warbs are the pits.
The pit.
These warbs are...
In the pit.
Wait, what's over here?
Nothing.
Okay, let's go.
I kind of want to eat this.
Like, it looks horrible and disgusting.
But if I think of it as like a delicious pomegranate...
It looks so like fruity and juicy and delicious, no?
I kind of want to eat it.
No way.
Uh-oh.
What are we about?
Oh, no.
Divinity statues.
Use divinity statues to trade red orbs for skill.
Wait, so we don't have Nico anymore?
Literal forbidden fruit?
Sparkly.
The car can't get in here.
I have faith in her.
Oh.
Whoa.
Let's see.
Let's see what we can grab here.
Why, why?
Pause.
Why, why, why?
I think I won't even do it.
I can't even...
I can't even get B correctly.
I try.
I don't...
He's putting enough spaces in between the Ys.
Oh, wait.
Payline might be good, huh?
Exceed.
We could do more Exceed.
If I...
And we can do more Breaker.
We can...
Let's see.
Maybe I'll do Payline and...
Oh.
Back to forward.
Okay, I'm going to do Payline.
Got some good news.
My hopefully last surgery has been scheduled.
Brandon!
This could be my last surgery to get my chronic pain under control.
I hope so!
Oh!
Good luck with everything.
Payline is fun.
Combo C, good.
Oh, this one.
Why, why?
Pause.
A flashy sword combo.
Yeah, let's try it.
Come here, buddy.
Come here.
Was that it?
No, but then the other one, he like, pushes him away.
Oh wait, that was it?
Oh, that's it?
Oh.
I didn't finish it.
Oh, okay.
That's...
I think it's just easier to spam Y than...
Just be like, why, why, why, why?
Oh, I...
Wait, hold on.
No, no, stop, stop.
Nope, nope, nope.
Not enough time, okay.
Like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can I ask for a small favor?
Can I keep my dog company while I go to work?
Oh.
Just call out Jonesy every time he pees on the carpet.
Oh, why, why is your dog peeing on the carpet?
Jonesy!
Pull my down on track.
Oh, I keep doing that.
I don't know why.
Quit the void.
Usually, once you've done the pause, it's easier to just spam Y.
I mean, it's cheap.
I guess I could learn it.
And it's just another combo to have that I might accidentally end up doing.
Wait.
But then also I can...
Oh, wait.
What I can do...
What I can do is I can do...
Breaker plus three and then also more exceed.
I think that might be good.
Because then I can hold more arms.
More arms.
Okay.
Now we go to exceed.
And I just gotta use exceed.
Okay.
Just gotta...
Wait.
What did it say?
Press and hold LT several times.
Okay.
Onward!
Quit the void, my therapist.
Oh.
Oh, these guys!
Okay.
Yeah, baby!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, I forgot again.
I forgot again!
There we go.
Woo!
They died.
Is that...
How this is supposed to go?
Or am I like causing myself more grief by not killing these guys fast enough?
Oh.
Nice!
Oh my god!
Where did you come from?
Nice!
Terminate!
Oh.
Why I'm jumping so high?
There we go, finally.
You wanna try that again, buddy?
You wanna keep trying that, buddy?
I can't see you anymore.
Come on.
Yeah, kick his butt!
What are you doing?
Woo!
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, damn.
Finally, you hit me once.
Oops!
Okay, you hit me twice.
Shame on me.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
How much...
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Haha.
Oh.
Victory!
Breaker!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't use my arm even once.
I'm so stupid.
I just realized that I was so focused on...
on...
on revving.
I didn't even...
I didn't even use my arm.
Whatever.
I'm too good.
I don't even need it.
Road divided.
Let's go this way first.
Haha.
Oh.
Dead end.
So many mechanics in this game, man.
I know, right?
Holy cannoli.
As soon as I'm like...
remembering one thing...
and I add another thing.
And then I remember another thing...
and then I add another thing.
Haha.
And then I'm like...
Okay, I'll focus on this one thing...
and then...
I'm like...
Oh, I'm neglecting another thing.
Haha.
But hey...
I still did it.
Alright, let's go.
Delicious!
I wanna be buried in whatever that stuff is.
There are no express elevators.
Someone's a lousy architect.
Ooh!
Barbara!
Why is the music kinda somber?
Get in the blood goop.
Oh, this looks like...
But yeah, I...
I think I asked earlier...
and I didn't see if...
I couldn't...
Sorry, I couldn't check chat.
But like...
when the...
when the thing drops...
is that what's supposed to happen?
Or am I supposed to defeat them...
really, really quickly?
That's DMC file.
It never stops adding things.
It's timed.
Oh, you missed a blurb!
Oh...
It's an act-time event for extra orbs and stuff.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ah, whatever.
Hello?
Anybody?
Nobody?
How you doing, Dante?
I mean...
Nero?
Oops, sorry, my bad.
Wait, where...
Oh, there they are.
Where is...
How is Dante doing?
We don't even know where that guy is.
It's funny, I even love Nero so much!
I'm so used to saying Dante!
The disrespect...
I'm sorry!
Oh, that was...
Hello?
Die!
Oh...
Why, why?
Why, wait...
Oh...
I'm too good.
I keep sending them flying away.
Come here.
Oh, I can't grab you.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Longer pause?
Why?
Oh, wait.
No, it's...
Oh.
I did buy that one!
Oh, no, wait.
I didn't buy it.
Wait, I didn't buy the...
I didn't buy that one, did I?
It's okay, I'll buy it next time.
You're right, you're right.
I didn't buy it.
Cut!
Oops.
I didn't even buy it.
And here I am, trying...
Oopsie!
Wait.
Stop!
There we go.
Wait, can I?
Hold on.
I want to try something real quick.
Can I do it twice?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
Funny thing is that Nero's VA Johnny Young Bosch also voices Dante in the new series.
That's confusing!
I was trying to place...
You know, I know Johnny Young Bosch is in, like, so much and he's in, like, everything.
But I was still trying to place where I've heard his, like, Nero voice before.
There's, like, somewhere that I'm, like, I really recognize him.
No, I didn't watch Bleach.
I didn't play Persona 4.
I don't know.
Probably DMC4.
What?
That makes no sense.
Lelouch?
No, I didn't watch...
I didn't watch Kokiyosh.
Power Rangers?
Maybe...
Trigun?
Maybe.
Who was he in Trigun?
Oh, Vash.
Oh, maybe that then.
Where's the ambush?
Ambush?
Really?
No ambush?
Nothing.
Oh.
Oh!
Scared me.
They punished me for... Oh!
They didn't punish me.
Aw, the game is nice.
This is my favorite way to... This is my favorite way to do it, but I have it so, like... It's so touchy.
Never punished.
Alright.
Good.
Finally made it.
Now, about that payback.
About that payback.
Oh.
Let's get airport.
Right now.
Oh, I see an arm over there.
Wait, does this break?
The music is so cool.
A phone here?
Does it still work?
No way!
Wait!
Let's get airborne.
Oh.
Nero, you need a shower, buddy.
You stink!
Boosh!
Oh!
So.
Bero.
Think you can make it all the way here?
Duh!
Who do you think you're talking to?
See, I knew she'd be able to make it.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Nero, you have a girlfriend!
Oh, he was asleep.
He wasn't even reading it.
He was reading the articles.
He's...
He's such a loyal...
Loyal guy.
Wait.
Come here.
Yo!
You just hear the window shop?
Yup!
Let's see.
What can we...
What was it?
Let's see.
Uh...
Can I even afford it?
I can!
Okay, I'm gonna grab it.
Wait, I have 7,000 Rorbs exactly.
Wow.
Combo C, baby.
Combo C.
What I can do.
Alright.
Now I'm gonna save up more for exceeds and for...
More breakers.
So...
The...
Would be good to also get this eventually.
Might just be me, but for sword combos...
I found it easier to look at the animation and imagine the tension in Nero's arms.
I...
Alex, I've been...
Actually, that's a good...
Like, I've actually been kind of...
Not...
Like, noticing that too.
Like, he kind of like...
He's got like a...
And then you do it, you know?
I get what you mean.
I get it.
Stare at Nero.
Let's see if we can edit this.
Cause...
Um...
I kind of want to switch Rawhide.
With a Gerbera.
We have so many Gerbera.
Wow.
Quit!
Yes.
The music's so cool.
Do I go up here?
Can I go up here?
Yes, I can.
Wait, come on.
Roller.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Nice!
Whoa!
Oh, where did you come from?
Where did you come from?
Yeah, get out of my sight.
Nice.
That's it?
Is there anything over here?
Oh, I think I go... Okay, hold on.
Before we do that, there was...
down here, I wanted to check out.
Over this way.
And then I also see... I see that arm up there.
Wait, which way do I go?
This looks maybe like a dead end.
I didn't miss the arm.
I totally saw it.
I 100% saw it.
Why is it so blurry?
Are my glasses okay?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
But I can't even grab it.
Because I already have full.
So... I wish you could grab them... and store them.
You know?
That's my one thing.
I've been kind of like...
Aw, man.
I wish you could grab them... and store them.
Deposit?
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, like I unequip.
Oh, you're so right.
Oh, that makes sense.
Let's do that then.
Yeah, yeah.
And I'll put one here.
You guys are so smart!
Good plan.
So we'll get rid of one Gerbera for another.
Hahaha.
If I can get up there.
Oh.
Come on, Nero.
I believe in you.
Oh, hey.
I believe.
Platforming.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice and easy.
Yeah!
Hahaha.
Don't forget taunt jump.
Oh, yeah.
I've been doing it like this whole time.
I've been doing it this whole time, baby.
Me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me.
Wow.
Why is everything so blurry all of a sudden?
Is it me?
I feel like the...
The atmosphere is getting a little crazy.
Ugh!
My eyes!
Aw, shoot.
Aw, shit.
Is it some sort of motion blur?
I don't think...
I don't know why I haven't ever noticed it before.
I think it's good to be king, huh?
Not for much longer.
Hehehehe.
Can I turn this off?
Game options, maybe?
Controls?
No.
PC options.
Graphics?
Motion blur!
We're... off.
Holy cow.
Okay.
We are safe.
Now we are safe.
Wait.
There we go.
Bibicor, thank you so much for the gift of Deku!
Aw, man.
It's a tomboy!
It looks like there's a boss battle in there, too.
LB can smash.
I know, but...
Wait, let's see if we can go back.
I don't want to waste.
Being wasteful is... Oh, I don't think I can.
No, there's no way.
It's just one, Garbera!
We can...
It's just one...
There we go.
Okay.
They give us so many of them.
Hey, douchebag!
Miss me?
I can't believe we're back here already.
Where's Dante?
Yeah, where's Dante?
Dried up Dante jerky?
Nothing?
You've come here to die.
He talks.
Your reason, huh?
I bet your parents didn't like you much.
Because your name sucks.
I am without a name.
I am power absolute.
He looks so bored.
No, no name.
I'll be sure to put that on your tombstone.
You will suffer and die.
Is Dante...
Is he like converted to bad...
To a bad guy?
I'll show you dead weight.
Round two, baby.
Maybe...
Oh, gosh.
Oh,
my God!
Holy cow!
Okay.
How do I...
Oh, do I fight this thing?
Oh, uh...
That's about to...
Oh, shoot.
I tried to dodge it.
Whoa!
Am I even doing damage?
Oh, my God!
I can't...
I can't tell his moveset at all yet.
What?
Sorry.
Wait.
That's the ball.
Okay.
I got the ball.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That was okay.
What-a-boo!
Oh, no, no!
Why does it have this little crystal thing?
I was early.
Is this even possible?
Oh, wait.
I just noticed how much health that thing has.
No freaking way.
I just noticed.
Oh, my God.
Wait, so I have to get rid of that.
Okay, wait.
It might be better to stay away from it.
No!
Hold on.
Let's redo.
Are you okay?
No, no, no.
Let's give up.
Yeah.
Yeah, reset.
Reset now that I...
You should say QDA.
It's okay.
She'll... she's fine.
He's covered in juice.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm all the way back here?
Oof.
Okay.
That sucks.
Skip, please.
Okay.
Let's, uh...
Go grab these, uh...
Roar...
But you already have a tomboy.
Oh, yeah, I do.
Okay.
So, I don't know if I want to get so close to...
Well, I guess I can get close to it.
As long as it doesn't, like...
It doesn't...
In my face.
No.
Customize.
Yo, you just here to window shop?
Stab out.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
But it...
But the gun was doing pretty good damage.
Not gonna lie.
It wasn't doing so bad.
Let's put you away.
And we'll grab...
We'll just...
This is a...
Wait.
Well, I have...
Wait, hold on.
Watch this.
If that...
If this...
We still have this tomboy.
But the Gerbera is back on the tree.
That means the other tomboy is still there.
No?
Infinite...
Infinite arm...
Glitch.
Infinite arm glitch, baby.
Why wouldn't it be there?
If this one's here.
You know?
Why wouldn't it be?
Let's get airport.
Right and high.
More robes, please.
Ooh.
Oh.
Too good.
Oh, this guy.
Wait, come here.
I think I got all of them.
Okay.
Onwards.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Uh-oh.
Right and high.
Let's get airport.
Wait.
Think it's good to be king, huh?
You can run past, but why?
It's not.
They're not.
They're just little babies.
They don't do anything.
Tomboy, tomboy, tomboy, tomboy, tomboy, tomboy.
Time to see.
See!
Yeah, free robes are free robes.
And they're easy bees.
Easy, easy peasy.
Okay.
Oh.
I wish I could like.
What's the word?
Uh.
Quick save?
You know?
Oh, save.
The save state here or something.
I forgot to rev.
Miss me?
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Did I just break my...
I just...
I...
Did it...
I forgot that tomboy could turn into a god.
Oh my god.
I forgot.
Wait.
I can blow that though.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep...
Getting this guy though.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
Actually, I don't think that got me.
But that got me!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't notice the...
Oh man.
This is...
This is a fight.
Already.
I'm feeling it.
Already I'm feeling it.
I've barely made a dent in him.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, run.
Sure.
Maybe it
was...
Wait.
No sir.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I...
We dodgero?
Mission 8.
I didn't see the freaking...
Are there any...
Oh shoot, ugh.
I don't see any health things around.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm almost there.
Right away.
Where's your motivation?
No!
I totally dove under that!
Oh my gosh, I dodged that though.
Oh, that's so lame!
Where's your motivation?
Checkpoint.
Cry.
Okay, I don't want Tomboy then if...
If...
If, uh...
I tried to use the gun.
Cause I...
I forgot about that.
Grab you.
Grab some more.
Wait, is there something up there?
Let's just notice it.
Let's see.
Up there.
Maybe not, okay.
There's a secret, uh...
I see.
Holy cow.
We're only on...
Let me try it.
Let me try it again.
I can't believe we're...
Only...
I haven't even beat one mission today.
I can't...
I don't...
I feel like I'm getting...
Gaslit.
I don't know.
It's fine.
I don't care.
Barbara is great for deflecting and Helter Skelter is a good shield breaker.
Yeah...
It's...
Not a matter of me forgetting things.
It's a matter of...
The panic.
You know?
Where are you?
Wait.
Oops.
I did the wrong order.
Stop.
Come here.
Why don't you come to me?
Oh.
Wait.
Can you come down?
There we go.
If it works, it works.
More warps, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Saving out money for stuff, at least.
Come here.
It's fine.
Oh, wait.
Did I grab the money?
Yeah.
Okay.
Just farming.
More money.
This guy is a doozy.
Oh, I forgot.
It's fine.
I forgot to put one away.
Remember, Mintz.
It's not your fault.
It's Nero for being dead weight.
I forgot to put one away.
Rev this.
Thank you.
Let's rev up.
Nice.
Okay.
Hey, douchebag.
Miss me?
Oh.
This fight is scary.
This...
Whoa.
Ouch.
Josh.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Please.
Get me out of there.
I don't know.
I get...
I'll try...
I try to get like a couple hits in, so then I can...
Uh, okay.
Yeah, I keep doing this, actually.
Okay.
It's working.
Shield of yours.
It's done for.
Oh, I forgot to...
Oh, no!
Oh, oh my god.
It worked.
Let's go.
Wait, is this shield actually?
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
No, no, no, ouch, ouch.
Get out of there!
Nero!
Get out, get out, get out.
Let's get airful!
Nice.
Nice dodge.
Oh, what the hell did that...
What was that?
What the hell was that?
I've never seen that one.
He did the work.
What the more?
Please.
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
I'm not timing these well at all.
Okay, whatever.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Okay, we kind of got saved, I think, by iframes a little bit there.
Oh my god.
I do.
I do regret it.
I regret my existence.
I regret my words and deeds.
Thank you.
Almost broken.
You ready to get slapped?
You will suffer.
Oh, I'm too far.
Oh, shoot.
Nice.
Wait.
Nice shot.
I did the wrong order again.
Here we go.
Okay.
All right.
Run from the lava block.
And go in and...
Nope.
Right now.
Let's get airport.
Please.
There we go...
Let's get airport.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shoot!
No!
I tried!
Myr axied.
We got out there.
Okay, nice.
Run, run, run, run, run!
Run, run, run.
How much left is on it?
Oh, just a tiny bit left.
Just a tiny bit left.
Let's see what he's gonna do now.
Okay.
Alright I'll wait.
Wait.
I'll wait.
Oh my god!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, DID I get it?
Wait!
Nero!
Come on!
Wait, Nero!
Come on, Nero!
Yeah, we got his hand!
Nice going!
Yeah!
Oh my god, wait, look at his tooth!
He's so cute!
Oh my god!
Urine!
Ur Oh no, no!
Oh god, okay.
No again?
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I'm trying to run around if there's...
Oh god, this is brutal.
Wait, this is so brutal.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Go back to it.
This is so evil.
Ouch, ouch.
Wait.
One HP and a dream.
Nero, I don't think this is it, buddy.
Oh, scripted.
I had a feeling.
I was like, there's no way.
Not with any...
Gorbs around, or...
Gorbs around, right?
Forced loss.
I'm here, oh no!
Okay, but I feel like when we fight them again, that's gonna be how it's like.
So, at least we...
We get an idea.
Maybe.
Duh-duh.
Who dares interfere?
Oh!
Where have you been?
I feel like I'm eating popcorn.
Yeah!
Let's be determined to seek out...
Oh!
May the...
That was...
That was yesterday!
You could've at least knocked, Morrison.
Yeah?
I could.
Literally yesterday, this guy...
This guy met up with Dante.
I got some good news and some bad news.
Pick your poison.
Which you wanna hear first?
Just speak.
Bad news it is.
Lady Patty's feathers are all ruffled.
See, she wants to invite you to her birthday party.
But your phone is disconnected.
Dante's not paying his bills.
You're a smart one, Morrison.
You notice the electric and water out too?
What?
Nothing less.
So what's the good news?
Oh!
I got a gig.
Cash up front.
Cash up front?
This, I like.
The water needs turning on, and those toilets need flushing.
Oh!
Oh no!
You could go somewhere else!
You don't have to use the to...
Oh!
We've been a real agency.
Let's see.
Oh!
That was fast.
That was so fast.
Devil may cry.
Tante!
Do you have any idea how many times I've tried to call?
Like a billion!
Oh my god!
Tonight's my first 18!
Not a little kid!
Is this the girl from the anime?
The little girl?
Yeah!
Okay, Morrison.
I'll take you up on that gig.
Yes!
Okay!
If you can get me out of that hellish birthday party.
Huh, consider your RSVP declined.
meet your new client.
Why don't you want to go hang out?
Listen, I'm gonna find a lady and Trish.
Bring him in on this.
What?
Come on!
You don't think I can handle this gig on my own?
It's a big job.
Big job, Dante.
You're gonna need the help.
V looking all mysterious.
He walks in and immediately slinks around the corner and starts reading a book.
I have no name.
I am but two days old.
He's a baby.
Just kidding.
You can call me V.
Okay, V.
Why don't you tell me everything about this job?
Lol, JK.
A powerful demon is about to resurrect and we need your help, Dante.
Who's weak?
Now that's a familiar tune.
Do you have any idea how many times I've heard that exact same line?
Just a prank, bro.
This is... special.
Special?
Okay.
So what's so special about this one?
This demon is your reason.
Oh.
I love the... Your reason for fighting.
The lady is just haphazardly pinned to the wall.
This demon got a name?
Oh.
Wait?
Why did it look like he was saying Virgil?
Virgil?
Vir... Why?
Vir... Virgin?
Wait.
Oh my God.
Is he asking... Is he asking Dante to take his... his V card?
Is that why his name is V?
He...
Mission 9.
Let's see.
Ah.
Wait!
Oh I did get, actually, a good chunk of money there.
But I think I...
Can't... Oh, Wait.
Uh oh.
We're back to V.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, Now-ho-ho-do.
Okay.
Uh uh I see, I see.
Uh.
Now-ho-ho-do.
Okay.
Oh gosh, I have to remember how to play as this guy again.
Once his card is taken, he will have no name.
Hence the poem.
Green Gainer.
He's still named V so that didn't turn out well.
Freak Phantom Streaks again.
Deepest Lore.
Oh gosh.
That's why the cane is called the Royal Fork.
I think I know his MO now.
I think I'm understanding what V is all about.
I think I'm beginning to understand.
Let's see.
Blockade.
Okay.
This is the bird.
This is the cat.
What's the bird?
Griffin and Shadow, right?
Oh wait.
Oh yes, there.
Shadow.
I was like, wait, these are all the bird's moves.
Um, okay.
I'll be honest.
I just... Here, let me show you guys what I do.
Since you guys can see my controller.
In the void.
Let me show you what all I do.
When I play as V, okay?
Are you guys ready for this really great gameplay?
Here we go.
Oh
okay.
I think I'm really good.
Can you even lock on?
Okay.
Let's lock on.
Oh God.
And it's peak.
I think this is lore accurate.
Okay, good.
Whee!
Is there even more to it?
Apparently, because you can do combos, but...
Oh my gosh, Dr. Bon!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
You're supposed to taunt, too.
Oh yeah, that's right.
And I... oh wait, how do I read my book?
I take out... it's RT, right?
I have to keep going.
RT.
Take out your book.
To see a world in a grain of sand, and a heaven in a wildflower.
All infinity in the palm of your hand, and eternity in an hour.
Oh.
Why'd you stop reading?
Why'd you stop...
And then we summon our guy!
Yeah!
We're optionizing.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Alright, I think... I think I remember how to play... a little bit.
Like when I play cookie cooker.
This is the gameplay.
Okay.
I mean, I could do more combos, but will I even use them?
Oh, I guess that we can do this.
Yeah, yeah.
That's our... okay.
A nightmare!
During promotion.
We don't have promotion.
I could get it.
But I... I don't know.
Today is also my birthday!
Yeah, I know it's Murphy's, too.
I said happy birthday to Murphy earlier.
Hi, it's me.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Don't need it?
Okay.
Let's just... let's just go in then.
Let's go in, baby.
Mission started!
Back to June.
June 15th.
You have so many birthdays today, huh?
May the Force be with you.
Eww!
What the hell?
Shoo!
Did you find it?
Oh, well, I don't know what I found, but...
I think I saw some demons dancing.
Well, then I guess we keep going.
The Devil Sword Sparta is nearby.
Oh, yeah!
Look at them!
I can... yep, they're dancing alright.
Can I still see them dancing?
Okay.
We got two ways we can go.
Obviously, the other way is probably the way we need to go, but...
What the?
Really?
What am I getting ambushed?
Oh, no.
I'm not getting ambushed.
Am I?
That's just because I started riding that guy?
Okay.
I forgot that I...
I forgot that I knew how to skateboard.
Sick'em, boy!
Take
out my books.
Oh, yeah, that's right!
Uh, wait, how do I...
Uh, then I do this, right?
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
That's right, I forgot about this part.
Oh, no!
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about the...
That they can't finish them for some reason.
What useless animals.
Is this...
Nope, that's a flower.
heheheh...
Yeah, we gotta...
Braababam.
Braabababam.
Bears can't kill.
Oh, yeah.
Just let that guy do his thing!
Heheheheh...
Oh, yeah!
Oh, oh, no.
Now he's doing his thing on me.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Don't let him do his thing.
Uh oh.
Behemoth!
Oh my god!
Oh no.
I don't like that.
And I think he's doing it over there.
This is so funny.
Oh my god.
Wait!
Wait, they're coming close!
Stay in the graveyard!
Oh no, don't stay in the graveyard!
Yeah, take him down!
Hound?
Don't take me down.
Don't touch...oh wait.
Uh, I see you.
Can I read...oh!
Uh, can I...wait.
Oh yeah!
That was fast.
Wait, what am I doing?
That was it?
What a pitiful sight.
I could steer him.
That's so funny.
Nyah, nyah, nyah.
Wait.
No.
Stop.
Grab the warbs.
Before they disappear.
More important than anything else.
Alright.
Onwards!
Oh, come on!
I tried to do a trick through the hall!
I wanted to do a sick trick.
The game denied me.
My purpose.
Tony Hawk noises.
Nyah, nyah, nyah.
To see a world in a grain of sand, and a heaven in a wild flower.
Hold infinity in the palm of your hand, and eternity in an hour.
Nice.
Keep breathing.
Keep...okay, never mind.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Maybe, like, actually get over to the thing, then.
You know?
Oh sh...oh, my god!
My animals!
Come on, animals!
Uh-oh.
My bird died.
Um...my bird died.
Hey,
come back to life, bird.
Slice him.
Yeah, slice him.
There we go.
Oh, bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo.
Oh, there we go.
Take him out.
Oh, oh, oh, that's me.
That's me.
Oh!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Team!
Don't let him get close to me.
There we go.
Come on.
Do your job.
Oh.
He's close.
Or no, he's there.
I got him.
And we got this guy too.
Gosh.
Lock-on helps.
Oh, is this...what is this?
Oh, oh, grab it!
Um...
Grab it.
Wait, how do we get that?
How do we get this?
Uh...let's see.
Hold on.
Uh...
Do I...
Alright, you can come back now.
You can come back now.
We got a gorb!
Cool entrance.
Yeah, baby.
Now I imagine...
This is not the way we have to go.
But there's some special stuff here.
Oh.
Pin him to the wall.
You should go over there.
Go over there.
Go over there and do the thing.
Oh my god.
Wait, this area is kind of really scary.
Yeah, get that guy!
Yeah, attack!
Attack!
Get him!
That was close.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Pin to the wall.
Oh my god!
I'm in trouble.
Wait, I'm in trouble.
My pets are dead.
Everybody's dead.
Life is not good.
Playing against V is so hard with some of these enemies!
Oh my gosh.
Playing against V is so hard for some of these enemies!
I fear!
Oh wait.
That guy.
Okay, there we got him.
Ouch!
Stupid ass.
Please.
Yeah.
Please just kill them.
What's not good?
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
This isn't.
Oh my gosh.
At least when I do that, it seems my guys come back to life.
Which is pretty nice.
It's
probably so close.
Oh my god.
Again?
Uh oh.
Now we're really in trouble.
Everybody, please wake up.
Please wake up.
Please wake up!
Oh my god.
Wake up.
There we go.
Okay.
We're just now getting back into...
Into fighting with V.
So...
Might take a second.
But holy...
Holy cannoli.
The angel that presided on my birth.
Said little creature formed of joy and mirth.
Go love without the help of anything on earth.
You can parry attacks with your cane?
Oh, I can?
Okay.
Good to know.
Keep reading.
To see a world in a grain of sand.
And a heaven in a wild flower.
Hold infinity in the palm of your hand.
And eternity in a power.
Oh wait.
Reading doesn't do anything except in battle, right?
That's right.
I forgot.
Reading doesn't do anything unless you're in battle.
I forgore.
Yes.
But I right now...
I remember.
I need you.
Oh.
Okay.
Don't fall down there just yet.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go back.
Unless we get...
Unless this...
Wait.
Oh.
Hello.
Fragment?
We came from over here.
There was some roars.
Oh, this area is kind of big.
Okay.
If I taunt, will I get more?
Only in battle.
Okay, nevermind.
Need DT.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
You're telling me.
How does it feel?
Maybe it's one big circle.
I'm not sure.
Please.
Maybe we can get something easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I can...
While I read and hear.
Okay.
There we go.
This is exactly what we needed.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Shadow, I need you to like go up here.
And then I read some more.
Oh.
I guess I don't need to actually.
Oh no.
Did they disappear?
I don't think I got it fast enough.
It's fine.
All right.
But we got full DT.
So that's...
That's really good to have.
Oh, another guy.
Oh, more guys.
Oh no.
These guys.
In fact, let's just...
Did he just...
Did he just belly flop his way in?
He sure is trying.
I'm trying too.
That's definitely a thing that I'm doing.
Wait.
This guy.
It's definitely a thing that I'm doing is trying.
There is an attempt happening here.
Oh.
All that DT we had.
Go in.
It's okay.
We'll get more.
Hooray for attempts.
Yes.
I like this area.
It's very pretty.
I like the flowers.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not good at these ones.
Oh.
Wait.
What's going on in here?
Is this where the...
No.
That's not where the blurb is.
Oh.
I keep forgetting that I can hit with my own heart.
With my own hand.
Wait.
Where actually am I?
I don't know.
Actually, I'm lost.
Actually...
I don't know where I am at all.
Can I get back up there?
Maybe like this.
Oh, no.
But I'm lost.
I don't even know where I am.
Okay.
I know I have a lost button.
But I don't wanna...
I'm not...
That's not what I mean.
I'm trying to figure out how to get back to where we were.
I'm so lost.
Wait.
We were here.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We were here.
And then we...
Okay.
And then we broke down...
That...
This wall.
But...
Uh...
We wouldn't...
Wait.
So I did go in through here.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Here we go.
Okay.
And I went through here.
And through...
Oh, I missed one up there even.
That I did not notice.
We're farming.
We're little farmers.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Wait.
Is this an easy one?
Okay.
This is just one that I can break.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Come on, bird.
Where are you?
Okay.
And then we go up...
And I...
Oh, he won!
Okay.
All right.
Let's do that again.
Drop me!
Once again, my depth perception...
Uh...
Is the true enemy.
Is the true boss.
Once again, my depth perception...
Uh...
Ends up becoming...
The...
The most difficult part...
Of the...
Of the game.
I don't have to get it, but I want it.
Okay.
All right.
But this is...
This is...
But it's also good training for me to...
To...
Do those.
Because...
Those kinds of trees...
I'm not good at those ones.
Come on, bird.
Take me up.
Okay.
Nevermind.
All right.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, stop.
Stop.
Okay.
All right.
In honor of 5-4, the depth perception strikes back.
Oh, yes.
Oh, oh.
You mean May the 4th.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
I give up.
I give up!
Oh, wait.
Not...
No, um...
Where was that blur?
Here.
How do I get to you?
Maybe I have to...
I think I need the DT maybe.
I think there's a warp in that room.
What room?
Need the DT, yeah.
Aw, man.
Wait, can I come back up, though?
It doesn't look...
It doesn't look promising.
Wait a second.
There's some stairs.
I might be able to come back up.
Oh, I th...
I th...
I think...
Maybe...
Uh...
Maybe not.
There's no other way to get DT than in battle?
There's no other way?
Back to where you were gliding to the left.
Huh?
Sorry, I was gliding in a lot of places.
I don't know.
I don't have any items.
Oh, there are no items in this game.
I'll go look and see if there's a warp.
Maybe.
Rack up a total of 16 minutes in the air by jumping.
No way!
I'm a jumper.
That's such a random achievement.
One hour of air time.
I don't want to just keep running around in circles here, though.
I want to actually progress.
I want to keep going, but...
I'll do one more look around.
If there was a warp in this area?
I see none.
Am I getting one guy to you guys?
Let's see.
Is it behind this house?
No?
It's fine.
I feel like I'm just wasting time.
I could try one more time, though.
Reload checkpoint.
No, it's not that important.
It's not that important.
Okay.
But I'm going to try this.
Oh, there goes Shadow.
Good.
And there he goes again.
Oh, I held on for longer than usual.
Okay.
All right.
Even if I don't get...
Okay.
Spam!
We did it.
Let's go.
Well, at least we got that out of it, huh?
At least we got the Rorbs out of it.
Goodbye, Blorb Fragment.
Such a tease.
But how was I supposed to know that?
I needed to use...
Keep my...
Wait.
Keep my DT, you know?
I saw someone say that I waste my DT in battle.
But it's not a waste if I'm using it.
If I didn't use it, people would get upset.
If I do use it, people get upset.
There's no winning.
Also, V is such like a...
A weird playstyle that...
I prefer to use it, you know?
You said I wasn't.
I prefer to have nightmare to take care of it.
The palace is...
A bitter place for me.
Oh.
You okay?
You okay, buddy?
Oh.
Oh, there's one there?
He can't reach me though.
Maybe.
Yeah, he can't reach me.
Oh.
Oh, now you give me a...
Now you give me some...
So rude!
Is there anything down there?
Besides water?
No.
Little bitty warp.
I thought I saw something over here.
My eyes deceived me.
Oh, this way.
Is feeling very dark souls all of a sudden.
Oh.
Eh, I can read.
Ouch!
Oh my god!
My bird!
This is why I like to summon my guy.
Because otherwise...
I'm in trouble.
Wait.
Oh.
There.
Yeah.
Let's get out of here.
There he is.
So nice of you.
So kind of you to...
Wait for me.
Okay.
Ha.
Golly.
See like this wall looks suspicious.
Can I break that?
This is suspicious?
Wait.
It almost looks like the other side.
Of where the blurb was.
Cause it has the...
It has the...
Eraticate the wall.
Oh.
No.
That's not...
Okay.
Come back.
Go away.
Come on.
Go to sleep.
Go to sleep!
Okay.
Just kidding.
I got a bad feeling about this place.
Turn around.
Uh.
What's that sound?
Or those...
Those...
Those guys that were dancing?
Hmm.
Cat.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
There are barrels.
I guess I have...
Wait.
But...
Do you guys...
Wait.
Where do I get this then?
How...
Or how...
Wait.
Can I...
I can't jump around it.
How do I get this?
Oh, it's at the exit.
Oh, okay.
It's after the drop.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
I ignore you.
I hate you.
Woo!
You, you, you, you, you.
Wait.
Not you.
Oh.
Can I...
Yeah.
Don't touch me.
I think we can get this guy too.
Woo!
Oh!
Rude!
Phil, thank you so much for the 10 gift, dude!
Warb.
I'm not lost.
It's called exploring, Griffin.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh.
We can fall here.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
And another.
Nice.
I think that's...
Oh!
I see it!
Wait.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Wait.
Can he pick me up?
Pick me up, Griffin.
No!
How do I...
Give me...
Lift me up.
I'm not that heavy.
How do I get high enough, though?
Oh my gosh.
Just move as soon as you double jump.
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
Yeah!
How many do I have?
Um...
I don't know.
It's like a nice little surprise.
We never know how many we have.
And then...
Then...
Whoop!
You just...
You just suddenly have enough.
Two out of four?
How do you guys...
Don't say that!
He has no reason to keep Dante alive.
No!
Dante's alive!
Don't just save words!
Upper right corner.
Oh, did it show?
And I missed it.
Okay.
Oh my
gosh.
He's going again!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Good thing that we...
He's the big guy!
He's released!
Okay, let's keep reading.
Wow.
So they do this...
Oh gosh!
Leave us alone!
Nice!
Oh!
You too!
Oh, you too!
I think we refilled our D2 though.
Which is good!
Good, good, good!
Don't speak!
Can these be broken?
I wish these could be broken.
Who knows what corpses hold...
They could hold value.
Wait...
Skateboard!
Aha!
I think Nero's doing a splendid job right now.
He only lost it a little bit.
Right?
Oh, it wasn't his fault!
Oh my gosh, sorry.
The camera.
Gorb.
Yeah, Nero totally is not losing it.
I wonder how many of these I have.
Honestly, I could probably start using them.
When I...
If I'm like really close in battle, you know?
I get a free one every day.
Who dat?
Oh, creepy.
No.
Oh no.
My nightmare.
My literal nightmare.
Shadow, I need you to get a little closer.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ooh!
He's chasing me!
Shadow.
Don't get snipped.
It's like...
The...
Thing is like...
It's...
Time...
For you to go to the vet.
Shadows getting neutered today.
Thank you!
That's me!
Oh.
Dang it.
Seems like he was close and then I missed the window.
Yay!
Oh, are there more?
Oh, yes.
Yes, quite a few.
Just a few more.
Oh, yes more.
Yes, more more.
Sick skills.
Take him out!
Hit him to the wall.
I'm like right on top of him.
You can DT whatever...
Now I'm nervous too.
But right now we're doing okay.
I'm not bad.
Rest in pieces maybe.
Oh, okay.
That's me.
Uh, you go.
Wait, you go.
Yeah, yeah, there you go, there you go, there you go, there you go, there you go.
Keep that, keep doing that, keep doing that.
Not yet.
Almost.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Anything around here?
No, doesn't seem to be the case.
I don't need DT because ROCK BEAT SCISSORS.
So true.
I can't see.
I don't, I don't know.
A shadow, the shadow skateboard makes me dizzy.
A little bit.
I get like a little motion sickness from it.
Because it's so fast.
Go back and stand on the coffin.
Do I get some rewards?
Thank you.
Wait, which, this coffin in here?
This one?
Give me.
Whoa!
Guys, do you see how many rewards we have right now?
Thank you.
For that tip.
Why are you giving me these?
Are we about near the end?
Oh.
Check and see if it still works.
Yeah.
Even if I don't need Nico, I still always want to call her to see what happens in the cutscene.
He didn't even say anything.
Don't be rude, V.
Oh my god, he's taunting him.
What?
He's...
This feels like a crime.
Oh.
Did he just call him a fat fuck?
Impressive.
I didn't see any subtitles for it though.
Sure did.
Nice.
Guys, give me one second.
You can hang out with Nico for a bit.
I'm gonna go grab some more water.
I'm gonna go grab some water real quick.
I'm back.
I accidentally...
I almost put on my headphones.
Like my big headphones.
Time for the earbuds.
I'm gonna also have a quick snack break.
Quick snack break.
I've got some calorie, mate.
Cause I don't want to spoil my dinner.
Just stopping by and say I got my good morning Minto chocolate bar.
Oh.
Awesome.
Oh my gosh, do I go?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Which flavor?
Chocolate.
Chocolate, chocolate.
Let's see.
Do I even want to buy anything?
Is my big question.
I feel like...
Oh, we can upgrade.
Wait, upgrade.
Okay.
Save for Nero.
I think I agree.
But this is also good.
He takes some...
He's increased defense.
Increased defense.
I was gonna say some of the...
Some of the combos that are just like not with lock on.
Because locking on is so hard.
I would save up.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll save up.
I could wait.
I could buy a blurb.
One.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
And a blurb.
That's like so much already.
Try the ending boss first.
Yeah.
We'll try it.
That's true.
We can try first.
Also, there's more robs right there.
We could have had even more money.
Aw, you missed your mommy.
You need a hug?
Why are they always talking about his mom?
Oh.
I just noticed that.
This...
Presence.
Oh.
It's the devil's sword, Sparta.
No doubt about it.
Um.
Do I need a DT here?
Or...
Oh, wait.
I'm sorry.
I just noticed this.
Oh, it's these guys!
Oh.
Nobody!
I'll be taking that back.
That back.
You know your endless worshipping isn't making Sparta any happier.
Kingdom Hearts nobodies?
What the?
Already?
Uh...
That's not good.
If that's too tactic.
I'll be sure to watch out the line.
Wait.
So...
Hold on.
It's my turn.
I'll leave the devil's sword.
Let's go after the algae.
The one that's actually attacking us!
Shuffering!
Get grabbed.
Oh, I saw an eyeball.
Slice and dice them, baby.
Six skills!
Where's the other guy?
Oh, here he is.
Spoken sexy style!
Oh, ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Just...
Angelu...
Long life!han141 Absolutely.
They don't want us.
Oh!
Ouch!
Come on, come on, come on.
Let me, let me...
Oh, no, no, wrong guy.
This guy.
Please, please, let me teleport.
Teleport.
There we go.
Okay, oh... No!
I had him!
What the hell?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I did get him?
How... buddy, like, it looked like he came back to life.
Oh my god.
No ice.
No!
You can do it, please.
And I eat while you do it.
You stink.
Oh!
Oh god.
It's too heavy for him!
Use those noodle arms!
It seems this sword is still too strong for me.
So close, so close.
You got a lot of heart, kid.
You really do, but you're a bit of a sissy in the strength department.
Oh, hey, hey, hey, hey.
No offense, son.
You know.
That kid Nero.
He has the strength.
Yeah.
It speaks.
Oh.
Who's talking?
I can't.
The way she's just dragging it around.
Dante.
Oh!
No way.
Oh my god, they, he dyed his hair.
Dante.
I don't even have the words.
I...
He's alive!
Yeah, he's alive!
The double sword, Sparta.
Was concealing Dante's presence.
Oh.
How does one friggin' guy have so much luck, huh?
No, he's alive.
V?
No, no, no.
Get equipped with yourself now.
Come on.
If only you could defeat Urazin.
If only...
Oh?
Hello?
V?
No, no, no.
If only you never existed.
V?
Then I...
Don't do it.
No, no, no.
Ah!
Damn.
I got an S on that?
No kidding.
I have 90,000 worms.
Yo, the cliffhanger.
See, he's not dead.
He's alive.
He was even being held so graciously...
like so delicately by that statue.
Come here.
Oh.
No, don't shove me in the closet.
You need to hide Dante.
No matter what happens, you mustn't leave.
Mom?
Wait.
I need to find Virgil.
I promise I'll be back.
Oh.
I know this is hard.
You must listen to me.
Be a big boy.
A man.
I'm a man.
Okay.
Mom.
If I don't return, you must run.
By yourself, alone.
No, mom.
You'll come back.
You must change your name.
Oh.
Forget your past and start a new life.
As someone else.
A new beginning.
No.
Where are you?
Well, clearly he didn't do that.
That was fast.
Oh my god.
She just ran in there.
Change your name to...
Oh, Tony.
Yes, I remember.
Tony Redgrave.
For a second there, I thought you were going to shish kabah me.
I know how stubborn you can be.
I thought it might be the only way to wake you.
Tony Redgrave era.
I forgot about that.
I'll do is it.
The 15th of June.
A month.
Pretty long nap.
No wonder I'm so stiff.
Right, sunshine.
Now put a fire under it.
We got to get going because that annoying.
Oh, my child.
Okay, but you were like, out of commission for a whole month.
He's just a baby.
He's my little baby.
He's much stronger than we ever could have imagined.
I think even Dante will agree with that.
May 15th.
This timeline is getting my head all screwy.
Hi, Trish.
Oh, it stinks in here.
Hi, lady.
I know.
It smells like hot garbage.
This is far worse than I thought.
There's no crime in turning tail, V.
These things might be a little too much for you.
You're right.
I'll leave the rest to you.
Okay.
He was like, yeah, you're right.
One must always have an insurance policy.
Okay, bye.
Who was that guy?
I can't believe he just ran.
No one special.
Come on.
Let's go clean up this garbage.
Hm.
First come, first serve on the targets, raw.
Music to my ears.
Hurry up, Dante.
Guess I get to see it with my own eyes.
If it really is you.
Whoa.
Player change Dante!
Oh my god.
Dante game mode.
Guns and soul... Wait, what's...
What is the equipment?
What am I looking at?
Oh, they won't let us buy any skills or anything.
That's interesting.
But we can buy porbs and blurbs!
I'm gonna buy a blurb.
Yippee.
Um...
I'm gonna...
See...
What happens now.
Before I do anything else.
I'm gonna wait until...
Because I...
Because the blurbs transfer over...
To everybody.
So it's...
It's not bad to have...
In general.
But...
I'll...
Yes.
What the heck is happening here?
Okay.
Mission status!
So does porb except for Nero.
Yeah, well...
Yeah.
Look how cute they are!
Hehehehe.
They're so cute.
Changing weapons.
L-T-R-T.
You can quickly change your weapon...
Press L-T...
To change long range weapons.
And R-T to change close range weapons.
Whoa!
Look at the armor!
Who?
Did that guy really do this?
Well...
There's no accounting for taste.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, okay!
Oh gosh!
It's all coming back!
It's all coming back.
Okay, let's try it before we try rebellion.
Yeah, give me some easy guys.
Test it out on... Oh
my god!
No!
There it is.
Oh boy.
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, oh, there it is.
Where's the other guy?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I'm not close enough.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
I see, I see, I see.
Oh, more?
This is crazy.
I get into the boat that's lost.
Oh my god.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Golly.
Because I used rebellion so often.
Sorry.
Because I used rebellion so often, it's weird fighting with these, but...
I don't hate it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Trish and Lady are so fast.
There she is.
Hi, Lady.
And Devil Trigger.
Yay.
Wait, what was it?
Aim back.
Oh, there it is.
I got it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, damn.
I don't want a Devil Trigger just now, but...
I don't need to.
Look at them.
They're just staring at me.
What was it?
Uh...
There was like... Oh, it was this one.
There was...
Hold Y.
It's too.
It's so good.
They don't even stand a chance.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting there.
Okay.
Oh.
I'll eat that.
Look, they're still so cocky.
Wait,
now can I buy things?
No!
Oh my god... I
can at least get Stinger.
Stinger's cheap enough, I'll get it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
How... How... Okay, without spoiling too much, if I buy all of this, and then I just play as Nero for the rest of the game, what was the point?
Wait.
New game plus.
Oh, see?
Oh, that's not really applicable here.
You'll play as Dante often enough.
Okay... Okay...
Hmm... Then... I'm definitely gonna get...
I'm gonna get...
The style level 2 for Sword Master.
I think.
Cause I'll use this one...
And Trickster.
This... Those are always the ones that I use the most anyway.
Flipper.
I'm giving them the bird.
Coyote.
Oven and Ivory.
Maybe I will go back to Rebellion then.
Hahaha.
But this was so fun.
Air hike, yeah.
Oh, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops.
No, no, no.
Air hike.
And speed.
Trigger heart is always good too.
Yeah, trigger heart is always good too.
Okay.
Those are pretty much all the abilities that I need anyway.
Um...
Million stab.
Is this more powerful than it was before?
Because before it wasn't so great.
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Hey, air hike isn't weapon locked anymore.
I didn't even think about that.
That's so nice.
Oh wait, we're on ball rogue.
I could get my stinger or...
I do like them in a rebellion.
Activate ten counts in blow mode.
Or heat up in kick mode.
Press A.
Hahaha.
So easy.
Easiest move ever.
Wait.
Is this just like...
It just kicks them while I jump?
No way.
Blast wave.
Oh my god!
At least it does like...
Oh.
Wait.
Is this what you guys were wanting me to do?
Or...
Do I need to be locked on?
Oh, hold it.
Wait.
Hold...
Hold Y in kick mode.
Wait.
What do you mean kick mode?
How do I get to kick mode?
What's kick mode?
Back Y.
Okay.
Whoa.
He's stylin'.
Wow.
Look at him go.
Wait.
Go forward.
Go close to him.
Wait.
How do I get... I just... I'm just... That's it.
That's it?
Press B.
I am, but nothing's happening.
Do I keep holding?
Now press B.
Wait,
why isn't it doing it now?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
He's moving.
Oh.
Yeah!
Hey.
I don't even... I don't even need to press B for this.
I don't even need to press B or hold Y to do that.
Wait, if we're Rebellion, does he do the... Wait.
Switch back to...
Okay, yeah.
He does do that again.
And why does the fire... Oh, okay.
Okay.
This is...
Oh, wait.
Then how do I...
Ah, I see.
I see.
Oh, I see.
That's how you switch.
Okay.
Oh, my God!
Holy moly.
Okay.
I think I'm good.
We'll try... We'll try using Balrog, even though I...
Feel more comfortable with... With Rebellion, but...
It's funny that out of all the weapons, they brought this one.
Of all the weapons from three, they brought this one.
Let's see.
Uh...
Heavy Jolt.
What is Heavy Jolt?
After charging forward with Heavy Jolt...
Do I even have one?
Oh.
Oh, you're right.
This isn't...
Wait.
This one is new.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
The other one was called Beowulf.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's right.
It was Beowulf.
They both start with B.
How could I forget Beowulf?
That fight.
How could I forget?
That's probably why I forgot.
I...
Um...
I sealed it away in my memories.
Okay, I'll learn this one.
Wait, no.
It's so expensive.
In kick mode.
Press...
R-B-L-S...
Forward...
Plus Y.
Off draft.
In blow mode.
Okay, okay.
Atrix again.
Uh...
Press RB...
Left...
Left stick...
Forward...
Plus Y.
Do I even...
Is...
I'm guessing I have...
Blow mode...
Like, automatically.
I'm in blow mode?
Oh yeah, what's the equipment?
Wait, so I can...
No.
I can't buy more.
So...
Surely I can't lose...
Them.
Surely.
I'll find more.
Okay, I'm gonna hold off for now then.
Just so that we can...
Get used to...
These things, you know?
Alright, now I have an air hike.
Which was everything I have there?
Look how cool he looks.
And we got speed...
Oh.
Alright, let's
speed!
Wow.
This is the worst...
Worst chainsaw ever.
Took him forever to break that.
There he goes!
Oh, here he comes!
Chaos!
Barb's Discord!
I miss having my...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I wasn't gonna...
Oh.
No!
Please!
Yeah!
Oh, there's another guy.
Oh my god!
He...
He didn't even have time to spin!
He didn't even have time!
Jeez, Louise!
The cheese!
Wait.
I also gotta try Devil Trigger.
Wait, what am I...
Oh.
I'm in a cutscene, that's where I'm in.
Oh, is it?
Or...
Oh, okay.
I might actually become the Joker.
Okay.
Oh, well, that's fine.
My god!
Holy!
I was trying to...
I was trying to change from...
From Sword Master to Trickster.
See what...
There we go.
But...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, sorry.
I'm getting used to Dante again.
Yeah!
Okay.
Come here.
No!
You son of a bitch!
That's...
That's what you get.
I gotta be fast!
No!
Dante, where are you going?
Please, kill them!
Kill them!
Oh my god.
It's hard when I don't have sword.
No!
You bastard!
It's all your fault!
I was...
Right there.
You do have sword.
Yeah, but I'm trying to learn a new weapon!
Yeah!
What the?
Oh.
I was like, who's counting?
Aw, shucks.
I was trying to learn, you guys!
Let me learn!
Oh!
Hello!
Come here.
Give me your warbs!
Oh!
Spawn!
That was easy.
Give me your warbs.
Okay.
Do these ever give me anything?
Or no, I wonder.
I haven't been...
What does he say?
Is he counting?
Nine!
Oh!
Because it's the fire mode.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Dress, there we go.
Teehee.
Any more?
Where'd Lady and Trish go?
No!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, we got it this time.
Oh.
Don't let him have a chance.
Just stun lock him.
Wait, uh...
How are we...
Trying to get into...
Uh...
And...
Why?
There we go.
Wait, you're not on fire though, Dante.
Look at him gooo!
Okay.
Kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick.
Where's the other guy?
Okay.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I feel like these guys might be better with...
Oh.
Wait.
I wanna switch from...
There we go.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Woo!
Oh gosh!
There's so many guys!
Just take him out, Dante!
Just take him out!
Uh...
Oh gosh.
When did I switch to kick mode?
There we go.
Yeah!
We can't let the exit...
Go this time!
Come on!
There we go.
Okay!
Yeah!
The exit!
Wait.
This one!
We made it!
I did it this time!
Yeah!
Remember how Dante didn't have any patience for Agni and Rudra?
No!
Look at him, Mr. Chatty!
Oh, another?
Ah!
It's just like a little area to get more roars!
I like it!
Maybe the kick was better!
It was better after all!
Is this where I'm supposed to go?
Or...
Oh yeah!
Yes it is!
Wait!
This way!
There we go!
Wait!
RIP!
LORB!
Wait!
What do you mean?
Huh?
What did I miss?
Oh, in the timed room!
Oh!
Oops!
Oh yeah!
I really did miss it!
It was in here?
Yeah!
I missed it!
Whoopsie!
Oh!
I...
Oops!
Oh well!
Yeah!
I totally missed that!
Oh!
Big guy!
Yeah!
This thing doesn't really do much!
I feel it!
I feel he just kinda like...
Stands around a lot!
Do some dancing around!
Nice!
Whoa!
Wait!
Where is that?
Oh!
Right here!
Nice!
LORB fragment!
Let's go!
And then I saw...
I did not see this...
But I saw this!
Yes!
LORB fragment!
Wait!
Where am I?
Oh!
Was this an optional room?
Wait!
Then this is not where I'm supposed to go!
So we missed a...
Bloor fragment!
But we got the poor fragment!
And said...
Oh!
I'm supposed to go down this way!
The very obvious open hallway!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh man!
They're already here!
These ladies work fast!
Hm!
The very big hallway that I missed!
Oh!
Long time no see!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Oh god!
My game is lagging!
I'm gaming too hard!
Ha ha ha ha!
Woo!
Oh!
Ouch!
My game is lagging!
I'm gaming too hard!
I lost my momentum.
There we go.
Okay.
I was like, how do I get back to...
There's more?
Oh.
Oh gosh.
I jumped right up to him.
Oh, ha ha ha ha.
Bad ass.
Kabo.
I deserve that.
Oh wow.
It was one hit.
Uh huh.
Cool.
And look at that, there's a yore there right for us.
After...so kindly after I use my DT.
Get some hail.
Nice.
And get some money.
Not...oh.
Nice.
Ooh, what is this?
Oh
no.
Okay.
I guess it's time for the big...HELLBAT!
I guess it's time for the guns.
Okay,
I'm using my guns on creatures that fly.
Ooh!
DMC2 movement, yeah.
That's okay.
Nice.
Wait, where are you?
Oh.
Did I get rid of the other bat already?
Oh god, she's so stupid.
This guy is so stupid.
So dumb.
Oh wait, I'm not in.
Uh...
Oh shoot!
Okay, they're actually...they're active now.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Okay.
They actually do something now.
I got too comfy.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Screw you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not good at dodging these at all.
Dodge!
Oh my god.
Oh!
I can't DT!
Oh no!
It's in aggro mode.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Am I dying here?
Oh god, it'll be so bad.
Last resort.
This distance.
While I...
Get my DT?
Help!
Ah!
She didn't hear me talking.
How many gorbs do I have?
Oh, I have 11.
Nah, I'll just redo it.
Wait.
How long ago was it?
How long ago was the checkboy, I wonder?
Get called stupid and it locked in.
Yeah, I got karma for real.
I got karma for real.
Not far back.
Wait.
Last fight.
Probably right before the fight.
Let's try it then.
I'm old.
Yeah, you are.
The last judgment draweth not.
Okay, checkpoint.
Let's see.
Blants!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It was right before.
Very nice.
Hold on.
I need more water.
Okay.
Bats.
Fucking love bats.
No.
Come here, please.
Oh, there we go.
Get them with stinger.
Yeah!
Oh, God!
Oh!
He's gonna explode!
Nice.
Where'd the other guy go?
Oh, there he goes.
Yeah.
That's right.
Alright.
Now we get these guys in.
Oh, I think it sees me killing its babies, maybe.
And
that's...
Yeah, I'm sick because I...
Ate your baby.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
CC!
Okay,
we kind of got it in a stun lock right now.
I don't know how long...
How much longer that will last, so...
Wait, it's not being so aggro this time, though.
What?
It's not even this aggro anymore.
Because it didn't get blood.
Yeah, it wasn't...
It was...
It didn't drink blood.
Oh,
I think I missed the door.
It was like right there.
I saw it open while I was fighting.
Oh, well.
The queen gets stronger by drinking the blood of dead enemies.
Oh, see, I thought it was upset that I killed its babies.
Of course, she doesn't care.
I thought it was a birthday.
Nice to see you.
Enjoying my favorite franchise.
Also, today is my birthday.
Diego!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the super job.
Happy, happy, happy birthday.
Sorry, I've never come...
Trying to drink more water recently.
I've been like waking up and my...
Throat is not hurting, but it's so dry.
Oh.
Um.
Okay.
Timed platforming.
We love to see it.
Oh, oops.
Oh, okay.
Alright, hold on.
He's so strong!
Wait, where am I supposed to go then?
That way...
Sometimes the environment is a little...
Uh...
Everywhere is so ugly.
It's hard to tell which ugly place we gotta go to.
Oh, wow!
They're gonna do that.
Okay.
Say hi, Droid and Minto.
You guys too!
You guys too.
Let's see how long does it take.
Oh...
Oh, they look so sad.
Okay.
This is our checkpoint, I believe.
Yep.
Nothing here though.
Wait...
I see the GORB!
Nice.
Is that the way I needed to go?
That didn't look like it.
I thought it was literally...
That's why I called it a...
Oh, it really is.
I called it a halfway point because...
I thought I needed to go to the right.
So silly.
I can feel them.
Who's coming?
Here.
There they are.
Whoa.
It turned into like an arena.
That's crazy.
Oh my golly.
Okay.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
It's just like fighting these guys all over again.
And then they all come after me.
One at a time.
Ouch.
Holy.
Damn.
Damn it.
Stop.
Stop blocking me.
The way they all line up is too cute.
Damn.
I should have parried that.
Oh.
Please.
Please do anything.
Damn.
Yeah, so much for that, huh?
What's the matter?
Oh my god.
Wait, is that the bros he throws?
Wait.
And we were all satisfied.
Oh.
He tried to dodge that.
Damn.
I should probably try taking like one guy out.
Like that, you know.
First I whip it out.
Then I thrust him.
I won't let you.
I tried to, I tried to get that guy.
I got another guy though.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're falling.
Slowly but surely.
I'm gonna DT the hill.
Teeheeheehee.
Teeheehee.
I'm not even finishing it.
Come on.
Wait, why isn't it working now?
Is it on a timer?
That's lame.
Oh!
I made him angry here.
My bad.
My hand is like accidentally... switching it up.
Come here, you're so fast now.
No, stop!
Stop backing up!
Stop playing like you're a real person.
It's freaking me out.
Here, I'll dance on you.
I'm styling on you.
Woop!
I want to go back to punching.
Oh, damn.
So there we go.
Holy cow!
Please!
Let me hit you!
There we go.
My goodness.
Good thing I won one at a time.
Okay.
Get her.
Thank you.
Yes.
Yes, I understand.
50,000.
In the boss fight, go all the way to the left in the arena and you'll get a secret weapon.
Oh!
Thank you.
Swordmaster upgrade.
Since I'm pretty much exclusively...
Exclusively using it.
Yeah, maybe, right?
Oh, no, no, no.
I don't need to try it.
Learn.
Let's try it.
Or let's...
Let's go...
Let's try the boss and see what happens.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you.
Game is so kind.
This game is so much kinder than all the others.
Except watch this boss fight be like horrible.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
I'm feeling it.
It's him.
I was gonna say, why...
Oh, wait.
It's just this guy again.
I can't...
All these stinking nasty pathways look all the same.
It's just this dude.
It's urine.
Yeah, I know it's a flashback, but I forgot.
For some reason, I was just like, yeah, we're just gonna go fight another guy.
I don't know.
Oh, king of stench and filth.
I'm impressed.
Those are two of the most badass women in the world.
So this is right before...
At the very beginning...
This is right before Nero came in.
When V...
Brought him back...
Brought him over.
King of stinky and filth.
Sounds just like me.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Don't.
All right.
All the way to the left, y'all, sir?
Oh, what?
Oh.
I should pay attention.
Can I...
How do I grab it?
Oh-ho!
Kalina Ann.
Oh, come on.
That was dirty.
That was so dirty.
This is so dirty.
I'm getting sun-locked.
Why does he feel...
Oh my god.
He feels...
Ah!
He feels more...
aggressive.
Than when I played with him with Nero.
Maybe Dante really did slow him down a little bit.
Oh!
Our baby boy is here.
That's it?
That was it for mission 10?
See, yeah.
11-11.
June 15th.
You know the rest.
Yeah, we know the rest.
My last hope, Nero...
Was completely useless.
Hahaha.
Get Nero out of here!
This was a bad move!
Nero, no!
You're just dead weight!
No.
Yeah.
That bastard call me dead weight!
I didn't come all this way for nothing!
Yeah...
Hahaha.
Rebellion!
It's so painful.
It's like watching MSF be destroyed in Ground Zeroes.
Hahaha.
You're like, no!
Up!
No!
Yeah!
Hahaha.
It's okay, Trish.
You did your best.
Wait, what did he just...
What did he just rip out?
The Devil Sword Sparta no longer serves a purpose.
I have plans for the both of you.
Eww!
How fortunate to serve such...
Divine purpose.
Alright.
I don't think I like that.
Enough's enough.
Can't let a boy...
Do a man's job.
Hey, wait.
I'm not done talking yet.
Oh gosh.
How much time is...
Is V okay?
Yeah.
By the way...
I guess I owe you one.
Is V okay?
Our sick guy...
Oh!
Is he literally...
He's getting Thanos'd?
Devil Sword Sparta.
Well, I guess we don't have Rebellion anymore, so...
No!
Wait...
Oh gosh.
Oh, we kept Lady's Gun too.
That's great.
Wait, so all my abilities that I learned with Rebellion that I paid for just now...
Oh, we kept Stinger!
Okay, okay.
You know what?
I'll learn Stinger too.
I use Stinger enough.
You keep him.
Thank goodness.
Dreads versus Sparta.
I just wanna start the...
I just wanna see what's going on.
Let's see.
Dante!
Okay.
Woohoo!
Alright.
Everything is so...
Ashy.
Looks like I overslept.
Time for a warmup, baby.
Maybe...
Oh, okay.
Oh my goodness!
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh, you too!
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Nice!
I think there was one guy over here, no?
No?
Just this thing?
I feel like we're in easy mode now.
It's so powerful!
We took care of that guy so fast!
Alright.
Um...
I'm guessing we just make our way up.
Making our way up town!
Walking fast!
Destroying graves is fun!
I'm suddenly back to...
Uh...
Back to...
Tomato town!
Oh my god!
Let's go...
I don't think there's a way for me to get up there just yet.
What?
Unlieued?
I did not lie.
I never lie.
Oh, keep going.
There we go.
It's a middle ground.
Making sure I don't miss anything.
I was so blind to that blurb before.
I was blind to the blurb.
They love sending these guys out.
They're just waiting for him to die.
You trying to attack me?
You trying to get a move in?
What is this?
We're
on fire!
We're on fire!
You trying to attack me?
What's the S time?
Oh yeah, let's see.
Wait, can I still do it?
Even if not in battle?
Let's see.
The stun is too good.
Yeah!
Looks like you just had your ass handed to you.
Okay, Dante.
He's a little party.
Come on, come on!
I didn't need to jump.
There we go, nice.
There's another secret weapon in this area.
In this area?
Like, well, I don't mean just down here, but I'm looking around.
I'm taking a little gander.
Oh, I already got it.
Oh!
Lady's weapon?
You get two.
You technically skipped it since you picked up Kalina Ann early.
Ah, okay, okay.
So I won't worry about it.
Thank you, though.
Thank you, thank you.
Everyone was so quick to be like, no!
Don't look for it!
You already got it!
You guys are so fast.
The naknowing has two roboters.
Oh, there it is.
No little pain in the ass.
Just gotta take it down.
Ahemala!
Come here!
There we
go.
Just gotta take it down.
Oh.
Wait, who else is here?
No one?
Okay.
I like how it just feels like...
This is not Beowulf.
I almost said Beowulf.
Balrog just knows how to talk... or how to count.
And we're in Sesame Street.
Oh, God.
Alright.
Um...
I didn't get...
3, 2, 1, 3, 4, okay.
Making sure I got everything.
Okay, cool.
Let's go down.
Making sure...
Okay, let's go down.
What's around here?
Okay.
Oh, take that.
Oh, that's fine, actually.
Not as far...
Of a fall as I thought it would be.
You can get double rocket launchers.
Oh.
It's okay.
I think I already passed it.
I don't know if I already passed it or not.
I don't really... It's fine.
I already have one.
It's okay.
It's for later only.
Oh, see?
Then it doesn't really matter.
It's okay.
Just keep going.
Yeah, we'll just keep going.
We're remodeling the city?
Chat is fighting.
Yeah, guys.
Stop fighting.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
It doesn't really feel like a spoiler.
I'll trust you guys that it is a spoiler.
But it doesn't really feel like one.
Maybe because...
Oh?
Aha.
Maybe because it just feels like a...
Like a weapon spoiler.
Nice.
No, I like to fight.
Chatter is wrong.
Oh, it's these guys again.
Oh, they're a little jumpy, huh?
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
Dude.
Wee!
Wake up back!
You dance?
I dance?
Let's summon Spartan!
We're worshipping Sparta?
Let's bow back.
He's laughing.
He likes it?
I'm on fire!
Show me dance?
Knock on beat.
I'm fired up.
Now it just...
Wait.
How do I...
Oh no!
Oh, he transformed into the grabby.
That's right.
You think you can handle me?
Oh, sword... Wait, what was I on?
How am I not on Swordmaster?
I am on Swordmaster.
Oh wait, I just gotta press the Swordmaster button.
But I thought... Hold on.
Wait.
That's what I was trying to do.
That's what I was trying to land.
I mean, though my dad works for Nintendo and he says you can have three rocket launchers.
If you beat the next boss, only your royal guard.
Why does mom let you have...
Why does mom let you have three rocket launchers?
Why does mom let you have two rocket launchers?
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I'm a bad.
Just seeing if there's anything else.
I guess not.
Okay, cool.
Well, mom's letting you have ten rocket launchers.
Wait, isn't this what opened up?
Or here?
There we go.
Mom's letting me have 1500 rocket launchers.
I'm the... I'm the favorite of the family.
Oop.
Wait.
No, come here.
No, stop it.
Stop doing that, Dante.
There we go.
Anything up here?
No.
Nothing up there?
Blorb?
I already got the blurb, no?
This is the spot.
What spot?
This case?
This is where the rocket originally is.
Oh.
Well, see?
It's not here.
I already got it.
So I couldn't have gotten to.
I could have gotten to.
I'm assessing...
Ohhoaaa!
Wait.
Can I just jump for this?
Oh, I think I've gotta be underneath it.
Yes!
Okay.
Cool.
Wait.
This looks like maybe...
The correct way?
What's over here first?
Oh, is this where I came from?
Oh, this is where I came from, just kidding.
We head back.
I'm not lost.
You trying to hit me?
I don't think so.
You trying to hit me?!
Yeah!
That's Dante style!
Oh my god!
Actually, what is the button to figure- to direct you in the way when you're lost?
I think it's left stick, right?
Wait.
What?
Oh, it's right stick.
Ah, I see, I see.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice!
Oh, I have to hold it.
Oh, it is left.
Wait.
Ah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I think left or right is just to fix the camera.
Like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
You trying to hit me?!
Oh.
Wait, this doesn't look so good.
Oh!
Oh, this doesn't look so good.
Who are you?!
Oh!
What are you summoning?
Oh.
Ah.
Haha, me too.
Hell.
Judico!
Oh, he's tough to get to.
Yeah, I took care of your- I took care of your minions.
Oh, I forgot that I have that!
Haha, quip!
Oh, you're summoning more?
Oh, you got a big boy this time.
fucking kh inquiring!
Oh, boy.
That's right.
Yeah, I parry your attack.
And I dodge it too.
And I also don't attack you.
Because I'm, I also miss... I miss some throws.
But that's just part of the method.
I do a little bit of a fake out.
That's just how Dante fights.
That's just how he works.
That's just his little Dante way.
Oh wait.
I almost missed that.
Okay, never mind.
I was going the right way.
I thought for some reason this would be the way.
This is the way.
Oh, reliable DT Stinger.
I know, right?
She never misses.
Well, she does, but you know.
Oh, you guys again.
Where's the big boy?
Oh.
It's just the minions?
Wait, what's that?
Wait, what's this in the sky?
Oh, is it Hellbat?
No, I'm not trying to get you.
I'm trying to get the Hellbat.
Ouch!
Yep.
And Stinger.
And... Yep.
And let's get you in the air.
Oh, dang it.
I was so close.
Come here.
Come on.
Hold on.
Oh, there.
Yeah, yeah.
And... Oh, I did not notice the flames that were being... Yeah.
Stop doing that, stupid guy.
Go explode over here.
Leave me alone.
Leave me out of it.
Leave me out of it, okay?
I don't want to deal with your little explosions.
You got your own plans.
Ah!
Oh, nice parry.
Red Zubai is...
App's name because he's just as annoying, right?
Why did I try to do that?
There we go.
Enterprise...
Haha.
Eww!
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
Oh!
There's another one!
Wait, there's another one!
...
Oh, he stood up.
Ouch.
Wait, what are you... Did you explode all by yourself?
Oh, damn.
Oh my gosh.
That thing gets me every time.
I don't like the Hellbat.
They're annoying.
I hate the Hellbat.
I hate Hellbat.
Wait, I thought he was gonna explode!
Oh yeah.
The slow-mo freeze frame with holding the rocket launcher was pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was pretty good.
Wait, was this room also optional?
But we got a pour!
We got a full pour out of it!
Dante's the only reason I come back to play DMC5.
Okay.
Something fell, no?
Oh wait.
Here!
Nope, just kidding.
Wait.
Here!
Oh!
Yes, yes, yes!
Wait...
Oh no!
No, no!
We can make it.
Oh, we can't make it.
Oh, many...
Many Rorbs were lost that day.
You can triple jump and D2.
Do I want to waste my D2?
Wait.
I have full DT.
Do I want to waste it for Rorbs?
It's probably like...
Can't a guy get a break?
I just woke up from a long ass nap.
I know.
Oh.
Can't a guy get a break around here?
Can't a guy catch a break?
I like these things though, because they drop health.
Well, I don't like them, but you know.
They're not as...
They're not nearly as bad as...
Some of the other little minions, you know?
Dante's getting old.
My old man!
Hi, Dante!
Yeah, easy green... green orb.
Okay.
I haven't really...
We're moving left or right during welter move.
What the hell is welter move?
Execute a counter in the direction you dodged.
Is it just a dodge?
Try it out?
I don't think I understand.
I think I can go get some more winers soon.
Oh, whoops.
No, no, no.
There we go.
So...
When moving left or right during welter...
While holding it.
Oh, so I have
to...
I don't think it's a win to walk on.
Oh, oop.
I heard of...
Is it not just the dodge that I was doing?
It's a body blow after dodge.
I can't tell.
Because it just says press Y.
It doesn't say hold Y or anything.
Hello?
I hate controls sometimes.
So like that.
Press Y again.
Is that just not a normal hit?
What?
Was that it?
Like that?
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I hate how I can't dodge when the camera is like, you know.
It's strict timing.
Yeah, it feels like it.
I don't get it at all.
It's fine.
I don't have to get it.
Mmm.
After executing a heavy jolt.
Most people don't even use it.
That's okay too.
I don't know.
It's confusing.
I don't get it.
It's okay though.
It's a-okay.
A kick mode.
Oh.
It's like not stinger.
Oh yeah.
Why?
I should just buy this.
Learn it.
Just to have it.
Do I not already activate the 10 count?
This is a stronger buff.
Oh.
Well that would probably be good then, right?
It lasts longer.
Ah.
We'll learn that then.
That should be good.
Since I use it so much.
Oh yeah.
It literally says effects remain active for longer.
Read VTuber!
Why don't you read?
Instead I'm just watching the little movie.
I'm like, I don't get it.
I don't know.
What's the move do?
I should just read it.
I'm just watching the movie.
I'm like, yeah.
It's doing a thing.
Let's see.
How much is an upgraded sword?
Oh.
We would've had enough.
Air trick.
Wait.
What was air trick?
I haven't switched styles at all.
I'll be honest.
Because I'm using sword master so much.
I'm using...
I'm using the punch in sword master so much.
It's the teleport.
I'm gonna get water in just a minute.
Wait.
Oh.
There we go.
Press.
R.B.
There we go.
Wait.
After executing a star...
Sky star?
Well, I don't even know what that is.
Once again, we love our illiterate Oshis.
How far does this work?
Like...
I'm running.
Oh, wow.
Really?
Wow.
What?
That's crazy.
Sky...
Sky star is air dash.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm holding me.
Come on.
Yeah, that worked really far.
Yeah, you do have to lock on.
But that's not so bad.
I'm going...
I'm gonna go to the edge.
Here we go.
Oh, but we're not locked on.
We're not locked on.
Oh, there we go.
Wait.
And you have to be on the ground, it seems.
Not worth it.
To me.
Not right now.
I love Swordmaster in this game.
It's so OP.
Okay.
I'm gonna go get some water.
Everybody.
Oh, wait.
I just quit.
Oops.
My bad.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get some water.
And...
And I need to use a little ghosty's room.
So just a short, short break.
I say break.
I'll be back in like a minute.
I will be back.
Okay.
Water.
There we go.
Oh yeah, baby.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
I missed the...
The...
Divinity statue music from...
For...
I'm not gonna lie.
I really liked it.
Alright.
Let's get going.
Uh-oh.
This looks like...
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Woah.
It doesn't look as powerful as before.
It's...
It looks...
It looks like it's been beaten up.
You're just gonna let me through.
Boy, wouldn't that be the day.
I'm...
I hear you, Dante.
Wait.
Let's look around a little bit before...
Isn't this where we fought...
Um...
Uh...
Isn't this where we fought...
The...
Guy before...
With, uh...
V?
The tentacle guy.
It looks...
Oh...
Maybe not.
There was like more stores and stuff.
Unless it's like all...
Busted up.
Now.
I don't know.
There were like more stores and everything.
It looks kinda similar.
Like a similar road, right?
Pairing you with your ideal home.
Dante looks so cool with his hair blowing in the wind.
I don't remember the name of it.
Oh!
A bike?
Hello?
Are you just riding a bike?
Oh gosh.
Is it Halloween already?
That costume looks a little big.
I thought you had better taste than that.
I thought everybody did more trip to Sparta.
Oh gosh.
How about I take it in a little?
Oh, the one that had the horse.
Oh no.
Okay.
I feel like this guy might be better with Rebellion.
How long?
Or not.
Rebellion Sparta.
Good thing I started moving.
Holy huge!
Oh my god.
Oh!
He did the same thing to me.
Yah!
That's right.
I parry you.
Oh my gosh.
How do you know my name?
Yah!
Oh!
What's happening?
Okay.
What are you doing?
I'm scared.
Maybe I should stop you from doing this.
Oh!
You got how scary you are when you're met.
Ow!
Yah!
Unfair.
Oh my god!
Yah!
I parry you.
Oh.
I love hearing the fist sounds.
They're so funny.
Whee!
Alright.
Hey, you can spell that.
I
don't know if I should...
If I'm supposed to stop him from recharging or what.
You know?
Nice.
I tried to get out of the way.
Oh shoot.
Uh oh.
What are you doing?
You can?
You can't stop him from charging?
Boy!
Heh.
Letting the put him bar, new power.
Oh my god.
Nooo!
Papary.
Yeah!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Okay, okay.
That's how much damage that does.
Yeah!
Oh, he's so far.
He's so far away.
You know what?
Actually, I will just leave him.
I don't want to risk it.
Okay.
Just a little bit more Dante.
Just a little bit more.
Come on, just get him.
Just get his ass.
Yeah!
What was happening?
Oh!
Trish!
Oh my god!
Be careful of her face!
Very god, Minto is real!
Yeah!
Thank you!
Trish!
Are we gonna be a speed demon now?
Or maybe a speed devil?
WAAAHHHHH!
S-sorry.
I didn't even- I-I-I didn't even- Oh god!
Dante!
Take care of Trish for me!
Oh yeah, oh yeah!
See you later, V.
You can't keep up.
This poor guy, help him up at least.
Booty shot!
We leave you here with the naked lady.
The game is- is... st-stuttering.
So now we got lady back, we got Trish back.
Look.
She looks so stiff.
What do you mean?
I took that guy down in one try.
Oh, yeah?
So he's not a demon?
What are you, then?
It doesn't matter.
I'm a shadow of my former self who lost everything.
I will tell you the story of my birth.
Oh.
Okay.
We just met.
Oh, no.
Do I have to play as V again now?
Do I have to play as V now?
Oh.
Cavalier.
Is it Cavalier Angelo?
Fused with a motorbike.
Creating twin blades wielded from the bike's handlebars.
Cavalier.
Cavali-ray.
Let's go.
Many of Cavalier's attacks inflict continuous damage from the rotation of the wheels.
Chain attacks and connect with...
Chain attacks and connect with spinning wheels to take advantage of all this weapon has to offer.
Remember when Dante first met Trish, she threw a motorcycle...
You're right!
I want to know more about you, V.
A few weeks ago.
Oh my god.
He's just...
He's a literal baby.
Suffering defeat after defeat.
That man's body was reaching its limit.
Breaking down.
But...
They were just born.
He couldn't die yet.
The man had a job that must be done.
Oh, that man from before!
To defeat...
His twin brother.
Virgil!
I mean, not Virgil.
It's gotta be Virgil.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Dante.
Definitely not Virgil.
Oh gosh.
Is he okay?
He's like a porcelain doll.
He's one of those haunted dolls you can buy off of eBay.
It's their home that burned down!
Aww.
I'm so sad.
Oh!
You don't have to prove anything to anybody, buddy.
That does.
Freeze.
My.
In order to defeat his younger brother, he could only do one thing with the crumbling flesh and feelings.
He needed to separate man from devil with the strength of the Yamato.
Shut up.
Imagine me.
The man became a true devil.
Shut up!
He gave birth to V.
Ha ha ha ha.
V.
Virgil!
V...
Vir...
Wait, so now without the V, we're fighting Urgil?
You're...
Ha ha ha!
What little demonic power I have left, but...
I'm approaching my...
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
Wait, I need... I need him to, like, slick his hair back now.
Is that why his hair turns white when he uses the double trigger?
I'm not your mommy, Ray.
Got it, Trish.
I'm not over this revelation!
I'm not over it at all!
I'm not over it!
This is... This is so peak, Dante!
That was so... That was... My man's back, baby!
We got a new sword.
Oh boy.
Is there anything that I wanna get?
Let's see... Well, we could, um...
Wait, let's... What moves does this thing have?
On the ground... Oh!
Crossline!
Oh my god!
Slip stream!
Back to forward.
Oh, those ones are...
I'm so bad with those ones.
Trish just got trauma dumped.
And her response was, dude, who cares?
Just watch the clip of you and Doki yapping.
It reminds me of my best friend.
Yeah.
Virgil separated his human half and his demon half with the Yamato to become V and Urgil.
I can't!
I can't believe it!
That was so funny.
Urgil...
Let's see.
Mid arrow.
Wow.
I'm gonna... Let me actually...
Let me just try in this...
Uh...
In...
With this weapon in general.
Since it's completely new.
The bike is single-handedly the most entertaining weapon in the game.
There's no going back.
What do you... How does it... You work like normal.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's slow though.
Oh, it's really slow, but...
Never mind.
It's fast.
This is a little bike.
Ah!
Wait!
Eh...
Okay.
Wait.
What about...
Uh-oh.
Oh no.
Just a little different.
I think.
Actually, I can't go.
You can hold each hit.
It doesn't seem to change much of...
Uh...
It doesn't seem to change much though.
Like, if I hold it or not.
See, like that doesn't...
Just tap Y.
Oh!
You mean like that.
So if I...
If I...
Do that instead...
Of doing...
I...
I get it.
Let's try a different one.
If you mash Sword Master, you get to do donuts?
No way.
Wait, I wanna see the...
I wanna see like the mid-air things.
Press...
Oh.
L.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot to jump.
I'm gonna hold B.
Wait.
I tried doing B though.
Where's my donuts?
I didn't do any donuts.
Which...
Dante has goggles on his neck from...
Wind Cavalier.
And in DT form, he wears them over his eyes.
That's so cute!
Wait, I don't see them.
Oh, I see them.
Oh, keep mashing.
That's right.
You said that.
Yeah.
Wait, am I...
Wait.
Should I not be...
Should I be holding something?
These are the weakest donuts I've ever seen.
Oh, lock on.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I don't know if I need to hold the...
Left stick or not.
Woo!
Ew!
TGS 2018 Cavalier's concept art was shown where it could've...
Would've been called Emperor.
It would've been used by Nero instead of Dante.
Maybe next game you can find...
Oh my god.
I'm stuck.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll try it in battle.
We'll...
We'll see.
Okay.
I'm not gonna buy anything for it just yet.
I feel like...
Oh gosh.
Uh, this might be my last mission since my voice is starting to get a little icky.
Icky, icky, icky.
Uh...
Wait.
No, no.
Um...
I could buy Swordmaster...
Or...
Level four...
I could...
Well, yeah.
Maybe...
Since I...
Um...
We can...
I could just get Slipstream.
It's not so expensive.
And that's a move that I can do.
Swordmaster...
Four...
Un...
Unlock some...
Strong moves.
Well, um...
Now I don't have enough by literally 300 Rorbs.
But that's okay.
We'll get those 300 Rorbs...
Um...
Immediately.
Pretty much.
Yamato.
Just barely...
Oh.
Woohoo!
Nice.
Oh.
You're here.
Oh, you're here.
Wait, why isn't it...
Doing the move that I just bought?
Hey, do the move that I just bought.
Oh well.
Wait, I bought the wrong... I bought the wrong one.
Well, time to try.
Like that?
Oh I'm stuck in here now with you.
Ew, I don't want to be stuck in here with you.
Like that.
Oopsie.
Whoopsie boopsie.
Ew.
That was it though.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I'm
gonna fight me.
Are you trying to attack him?
I'm doing like the least amount of style points.
But I think this is the most amount of style points in my heart.
This is the most style points in my heart.
Spin to win.
Are these gonna drop anything?
They just drop to the ground.
And then they rebuild.
It's like a metaphor.
For life.
When you drop to the ground, you just gotta rebuild yourself.
Ooh.
Pretty area.
It's been like almost untouched.
Wise words.
Be like... Whoops.
Don't be like me.
Have depth perception.
Be like...
Be like this overgrown monster city.
Oh nevermind.
That's a stoplight.
Nope.
I'm examining you.
I'm examin... Nope.
Nope.
Dante.
I'm examining you.
Is it puzzle time?
Oh my gosh.
Actual puzzle.
You need some blood, huh?
Sorry.
You wouldn't like mine.
Wait.
How do I have a Nidhogg hatchling?
From where?
When did I... When did I... Wait.
There's blood all right here.
Wait.
Examine.
When did I grab that?
Oh.
I need to grab one.
Okay.
I was like... Wait a second.
I don't have that.
Yeah.
No.
No shit.
Come on.
Minto.
Use your brain.
It was just a prompt.
Oh guys.
VTuber's so dumb.
Right?
Can I get a... Yeah.
Think Minto.
Think.
Okay.
We gotta go find two of them.
Two of them.
There's a little guy.
Oh.
Grab.
Don't be super smart.
She has glasses.
True.
So true.
Thank you.
We'll use this one first.
Which one gives me a second one?
Or do they both?
Which one should I go through first?
Either one.
Doesn't matter.
Oh.
This area reminds me of something DMC1.
There... I know exactly what area you're talking about.
Brandon.
In DMC1.
It does remind me of that area too.
Now that you mention it.
Alrighty.
Here we go.
Oh.
Yeah.
There was that area where... I think it was the dogs first appeared.
No.
Yeah.
Wait.
It was like a razor... It was something... It was something razor-like and like flying through the air.
I remember.
That area was... It was tough.
Oh.
I'm not gonna let you drink their blood.
Yeah.
That fight sucked.
Wait.
There's blood right there.
Don't let her drink it.
Come on, Dante.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't let her drink it.
Wait.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
This
is such a silly... Yeah!
Ooh, I parried that.
Let's go.
Gosh, dang.
Dang.
Actually, I don't even know if she would drink that up.
I don't even know.
What is this?
What is that?
Just some gunk.
Maybe it wasn't blood after all.
It's a silly weapon.
There it is.
Who?
Oh.
Hey, chill out.
Yeah, you wanna fight this?
Fire beats ice.
Baby!
Exactly!
Oh, it just respawns.
Okay, that's fine.
I think that's all I had left in here.
And then we can get this guy.
Wait, is this where I came?
No, this is not where I came from.
I came from... This way?
Yeah.
Oh, God.
We are going the correct way.
Oh, whoa.
That's... That was... That kind of sucked.
We are going the correct way.
Yeah!
So many warbs!
Holy moly.
Oh.
That leads back.
And this leads to...
If I follow these grooves...
Grooves?
When it down, smack it.
So true.
Oh!
I see.
With bees' revelation, does the bird and panther summon look familiar to you.
Like a certain bird boss and spiky panther from DMC.
What?
Oh!
Well, I guess when you mention it...
When you mention it...
Okay.
Yep.
Here comes the blood.
Doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
And I say...
Um...
Oh!
Porb.
That's what I say.
I've always said that.
That's like my motto.
Ever since I debuted, I've always been like...
Porb.
Oh!
This is what...
Aha.
I see.
Yeah, I've always said that.
Then...
You know, I've never played Devil May Cry before, but...
When I debuted, I was just like...
I was like, I just feel this connection.
This connection to the word Porb.
The trees.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, I don't like that.
It's Porb.
Worst enemy incoming.
Hard but fun enemy.
Oh, boy.
Bang!
Bang.
You get him.
Fury.
I have a PTSD with an enemy of that name.
Where is he?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Oh shoot.
Oh, get up, Dante.
Okay.
Maybe, maybe, uh... Maybe, uh... Maybe, uh... Maybe, uh... Maybe, uh... Oh my gosh.
What the hell?
Wait,
please.
Go back to...
No.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Excuse me.
Please.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I got his ass.
No.
Oh.
I wasn't... I wasn't even focusing on him because I was trying so hard to... Get back into, uh... Into punching mode.
That's all I wanted to do.
Hahaha.
I wasn't even looking at him.
I was just like, okay, I need to go back.
I want to go into punching mode.
And I couldn't... I couldn't get to it.
Hahaha.
But in the end... DT'ing is, uh... Oh.
Is, uh, what helps.
You need to parry him to get good hits.
Yeah, I could kind of tell.
He was, like, that type, you know, but...
In the end... It's all good.
How do I... How... How do I get it?
Oh my gosh.
If only I had a grabby-grab.
And then we are all satisfied.
Exactly.
Squeeze.
Dante can make it through there.
I'm not gonna lie.
He's just being lazy.
Hahaha.
I was hoping I could just follow the groove.
But they're not making any sense of it.
Dang.
Okay.
What the... Is it that thing?
Hahaha.
Hmm?
Is it that thing?
What is that thing?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, it's this thing.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
It's a nest!
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm not ready.
Oh my gosh, a nest.
Nope, nope, nope.
I'm not letting...
No!
I'm not letting you...
Even...
Even attempt.
I think this is our first time actually fighting this.
Oh my gosh.
It's our first time like actually fighting this.
No, I did not mean to grab that.
Oh my gosh.
Can I get rid of this guy?
There we go.
Okay.
Easy.
I really like...
Having the fists.
I didn't like...
I didn't like Beowulf so much.
But these ones...
These ones make it hard to say no, you know?
These ones make it hard for me to...
Strange camera angle.
Yeah, we'll have to get Swordmaster level 4 once...
Once...
I find a statue.
I guess...
I guess Dante doesn't know Nico.
So he wouldn't know to call her.
How does Nero know Nico?
Something, something...
Don't want to keep Mr. Demon King waiting.
Gotta pick up the base.
Something, something pre-DMC...
Five novels.
There's novels?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Wait, can I...
Okay, there's no holes I can jump through.
I guess I can go in through here.
Is this how I get to the...
To the board?
Yes, it is.
Oh, there's...
Oh...
This is how we get to the Bloorb.
Nice.
One full Bloorb!
Yippee!
Alrighty.
Uh...
Wait, where's the exit?
Dante, where was the exit?
Oh.
I found it.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Full.
Deviled.
Perfect.
Okay, let's just... Warp.
Not even just a warp.
It's a warp tree.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I don't know why I didn't think there would be a... Stop
freezing me.
Don't do that again.
Yeah, don't do that again.
I'll make it so you never have the chance to do it again.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
I was getting it.
Woohoo!
Yip, yip.
Cool.
Alright.
More blood.
More blood for the blood god.
Oh, my gosh.
Corb.
I like how you find secret passages that I missed while not seeing obvious big corridors.
It's my... It's my special talent.
It's my... Don't worry about it.
It's just, you know...
It's my special talent.
What, there's one more that we need, I think?
One more blood puddle?
One more...
The VTuber experience?
That should be all of them.
Just kidding.
That's all of them.
It's been a while since I used my brain this much.
Oh, Dante.
You really are just like me.
Ghost gamer skills.
Dante is too real.
He is too...
He's too real.
Just like me, for real, for real.
Okay, we gotta make it to...
Oh, so close.
Imagine if there was fall damage in this camp.
Gorb.
Insert the baby.
The baby causes mold.
Is this...
Uh...
What is this?
Where are we going?
Oh my goodness.
Seriously?
Where?
Oops.
You wish to fight me!
You wish to try and attack me!
Oh, he did...
Oh yeah, he did...
Oh.
I-YOU!
Yeah, no.
You, then you.
Then, you, then you...
I feel bad.
I feel like these weapons have...
They've stopped my ability of trying to do combos.
As soon as I start playing Nero again, this playstyle makes my brain so smooth.
Was it just a shortcut?
Aw, man.
Oh, see, I thought that this room...
Oh, okay.
That's why I didn't walk over to it.
I thought that this room was... Hold on, I'm pretty sure it's at the beginning.
I thought it was one of the rooms that we started out with, so I was like, oh, it just made a circle.
But it doesn't.
Nice.
Can't see.
Oh.
I wish... I wish we didn't go back.
Dante, I'm... I've paid my dues.
Oh, I see the secret level here.
You see that?
I see that.
I see that secret mission.
Why is the music so cute?
Why is it so fancy and cute all of a sudden?
Is it because we're being nostalgic?
It's okay.
I don't need the secret.
I don't need the secret mission.
And I don't want to do the secret mission, you guys.
It's fine.
99% of them I can't complete anyway.
99% of them I'm... I'm stuck at.
So it's fine.
There we go.
Oh!
Now we can get it.
Now we can...
We can get the...
Swordmaster.
Swordmaster 4!
Wheelie Jump 2.
Dance Macabre.
Real Impact.
Pyro Mania.
99% of Minkies quit before they hit it big.
Now, what was the one I wanted to buy?
Oh, it was this one.
Okay, I'll learn it.
Instead, I learned...
Slipstream.
Okay.
I'm good for now.
Whoa.
I can't believe any of this is still standing.
The music is so emo-y.
This little home.
You're home, doctor.
Hold on.
We'll do a dramatic walk-in.
Cinema.
Why is Mama the only one that looks good?
Here you are.
Oh.
Hello, Griffin.
Hey, what's wrong with you?
Hey!
Hey, Dante!
The demonic power was activated in me once.
When Virgil lovingly jammed this through my chest.
Hehe.
I always wondered...
Why did my father give me the rebellion?
Okay.
What are you muttering?
Over the years, I've been stabbed and jabbed by a number of things.
But who would have ever guessed?
Have you lost your mind?
There's a demon to destroy.
Kill yourself later.
If the Amano can separate man from devil, then what about the rebellion?
No!
Absorbing the Sparta!
Oh!
He's hulking out!
Oh my god!
And that's when he goes to save Nero!
Oh!
Dad, damn!
Holy bakery!
It can't be.
Dante.
Son of a bitch.
I know you couldn't be killed that easily.
Yeah!
Hey.
He's all yours.
But don't let it... become a habit.
I love Miro.
Win, Dante!
Win!
But now he became literal deadweight.
Devil's sword, Dante.
He evolved... Pokemon style.
Devil's sword, Dante!
A blade born.
When Dante absorbed the rebellion into his body, the weapon shares both his name and his will.
Does Dante have an ass to surpass?
That was... that was really...
You guys... oh my gosh.
There was like that one meme of the guy...
like squatting down.
Like looking from behind.
Or he was like looking over...
He was like a big superhero guy.
That's what it reminds me of.
The best DT in the series.
Omni-man?
Maybe.
The basic abilities of rebellion and Devil Sword Sparta carry over to this blade.
Impressing B in Sword Master style conjures swords that attack autonomously.
Use the blades in tandem for a relentless wave of hack and slash carnage.
Oh, I will.
Activating Devil Trigger!
Wait, I can still activate Devil Trigger in this form!
With this equipped, we'll conjure swords that provide different types of support depending on your style.
These include higher mobility, simultaneous attacks, automatic counters, or strong defense!
Oh, oh god.
Okay.
Wait.
Am I doing this right?
Oh, oh, Dante.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold LB to change from the DT to the SDT gauge.
There is a new gauge above the DT gauge.
I was pressing B like it told me to.
Do I have to lock on and press B?
B is teleport.
Oh.
Wait, but it just told me.
It just told me to.
As far as normal form.
My god.
That's being in regular...
Okay, I got it.
Hold LB to change from the DT gauge to the SDT gauge.
There is a new gauge above the DT gauge.
The sin double trigger.
To fill this gauge, transfer power from the DT gauge by holding down LB.
Charge SDT gauge to max.
Then hold LB.
Okay.
I think I get it.
So I hold LB.
And then I...
Hold it to transform.
Just hold until...
Full and glowy.
Sounds good to me.
Oh.
I'm figuring this out.
Wait, so now if I...
Oh, I see them.
That's so cool.
Cool.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright.
Oh my god, they bounce now.
Let me
just...
Okay, that didn't work.
And then last.
And it's close.
Okay, now how do I...
Get into this mode.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm figuring it out.
Oh.
Oh, Dante.
Please.
It's so strong though.
Let's transfer.
Okay.
Ouch.
I thought you stomp.
Oh my god.
This stinking...
I'm gonna become the Joker.
I hate the tentacles.
Yeah, let's try that again.
Now that I get it.
So let's try that again.
Let's try it again.
And the...
Now that I...
I was like so...
My brain was like still trying to...
To...
To absorb the information.
Redoo.
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah, more time to play with it.
True.
Oh wait, where am I?
Oh.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
Oh, we're at our house.
Okay.
Holy shit.
I can't believe any of this is still standing.
So can I use all my like old moves too?
Like stinger and things like that or...
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Oh no, yes.
New moves you have to buy?
Not yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
Well, I'll just not get so far away from it.
Because I think the tentacles are what the...
Is pretty...
Wait, okay, hold on.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Okay, we broke it now.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
That's so evil.
Please, game.
Nowhere to go.
I'm not even that far away from you.
Don't spam it.
That's rude.
Don't do it.
It's rude.
Don't do it, it's rude!
It's okay, we're back, baby.
We're back, baby!
He's so small compared to this dude.
Nooooo!
Evil, evil, evil.
Wait, it's actually not back.
As long as you live.
Oh my god.
I was trying to get health.
Come on, come on!
Hold, hold, hold, hold, hold!
I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding!
Why isn't it working?
Why?
Why won't you transform?
There we go.
Oh, I have to release it.
That's right, you're right.
I'll keep forgetting.
Come on, just a little bit more!
Yeah!
All this time, and you still don't get it.
What?
It is you who does not understand.
What's happening?
What?
It has begun.
What do you mean?
What, why was it so dependent on the time?
It's tea time.
Twelve o'clock.
It's, it's time for lunch.
Uh oh.
What's happening?
Yeah, that's what I'm asking too.
Bad news!
Gotta go now!
That house plant is pissed off!
Oh my god.
Oh, Trish, you might need to like, princess carry this guy.
Come on!
Come on, Trish!
Nice win game, I think.
I don't feel like I gamed that one, but that's okay.
It was just a bunch of power.
It was just really strong.
The cloud fog is revealed in its entirety.
This inconvenience.
Oh, he's going in.
Oh, it looks so yummy.
Oh!
Oh, I think I got C's across the board, baby.
How did I get a B?
I literally got all C's, and then I was just like...
Eh, B.
Now that the cat is out of the bag, if you look up videos of Urizen's voice...
Pitched up, it'll be Virgil's voice.
What?
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
A 1.2 multiplier.
Yippee!
Yay.
Also, I just realized I had the audio up for that whole time.
I'm sorry if it was really loud.
Am I ready?
Yeah, what is Urizen after?
He's at the top.
Of the Klyphod.
It's the other way around, Dante.
This is the lowest level of the Klyphod's upper echelon.
Echelon.
Human blood is the source of demon's power.
The fruit born through the Klyphod is even more dense than the blood that created it.
Its power is unparalleled.
Even the almighty Mundus used it to become king of the outer world.
Oh.
He's a little smirk.
Yeah, well, that's a lovely story and all, but...
As long as we know where to find him.
Whoa, you!
I'm the infamous Dante.
I'm Nicoletta Goldstein.
Tell familiar?
My grandmother is... is Nell Goldstein.
The gunsmith that made all your fancy weapons that you got...
Back there.
Yeah, there she is!
Oh!
You don't much look like her.
Yeah, I got my looks from my daddy.
That's about all I got from him.
But based on his research, I managed to cobble this.
What the hell?
Consider it a gift.
In honor of us finally meeting.
Yee-haw!
Meeting.
Meeting?
Oh!
Oh my god!
No!
No, no!
It's happening again!
I'll take that.
Dante.
I'm gonna go too.
Why don't you sit this one out?
Oh.
That you call me dead weight again?
No, thanks.
He really hates that.
I don't have the power I need.
Right here!
You don't understand.
It's not what I mean.
Let him go, Dante.
Time is a luxury that we can no longer afford.
We must chase after him, post-haste.
What?
Does that mean you're going too?
I have a duty to see this through.
Oh god.
You are looking really rough.
Well, that's all you had to say, Mr. Poetry.
He is looking real.
I'm gonna go my way.
And you guys can go yours.
Oh god, he's actually flaking away.
Let's just say that's the best for the cause.
My chat broke.
Hold on.
I'll refresh it after this.
Poor sick boy.
Dr. Faust!
A red hat that consumes robs to launch special attacks.
Earn tons of robs from foes if you don't run out of your own fur.
Oh.
Gamble...
Alchemical...
Alchemical gambler's garb!
Dr. Faust consumes robs to attack foes.
Most attacks require a sufficient amount of robs to use.
The robs consumed are displayed on the upper right side of the screen.
Keep an eye on your balance and don't spend them all.
Using Dr. Faust's skill set...
Skill set hat!
Lets you earn a ton more robs.
Strike foes with the hat, then go on the offensive.
Gotcha, gotcha hat!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I don't...
I don't know who I want to play as yet.
Hold on.
Let me reset my chat real quick.
One moment, please!
The robs.
The robs!
Roar pot.
Dante's the right answer.
Not gonna lie.
I'm having a lot of fun with Dante.
Give him the hat!
So the hat is made from the flying Faust demons from DMC4 and it's busted as all heck.
Seriously?
Ugh!
Well guys...
We're on mission 13.
That means we have...
8 more...
I only got through...
Wait...
No, I got through a handful.
I started at mission 8.
8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
We got through 5 missions today.
So...
So 8 more.
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
Yeah.
7 left.
No, I thought it was...
I thought it was...
20.
So...
We have to do mission 13.
Which...
The final two are short.
Oh really?
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, you will include 13.
So it's uh...
So it's 8 more.
Right?
Yeah, 7 after this mission.
Do you think it'll take about the same amount of time that it took me today?
Anyway...
I also...
Kind of dilly-dallied a lot.
Running around.
Doing silly mumbo-jumbo.
Um...
Some are short.
Depends if you learn or not.
Hahaha.
Cause I want to finish tomorrow.
Maybe I'll just start at the same time tomorrow then.
Maybe I'll start at the same time tomorrow then.
Cause I want to beat it tomorrow.
Yeah.
Mm.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do that then.
Um...
I think that's okay.
Cool.
Then!
Um...
Yes, yes, yes.
What?
Did I miss?
Oh.
Villain!
Thank you so much for the Haka Zuba!
Wait, I think I missed it earlier.
A little backstory.
An interview with DMC Devil May Cry people.
They talked about how their Dante was super cool and banged chicks.
How he's not a gay cowboy.
Or Michael Jackson rip-off.
Cowboy.
Hahaha.
DMC loves to reference everything.
Wow.
I love that.
Yuni!
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you.
Hahaha.
That's so funny.
Yeah, I need...
I need to...
I need to go eat.
I'm so hungry.
And I didn't eat breakfast.
So...
Um...
I kinda haven't eaten all day.
I had...
I had a protein bar for breakfast.
So...
I'm pretty hungry.
And...
Um...
Hahaha.
It's 8.30pm for me.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Oh, sad I'm going to miss this week's stream due to company visiting.
No!
It's okay!
In case we finish tomorrow...
Here's a...
I will finish tomorrow.
Mark my words.
I will.
So...
We'll...
We'll reconvene tomorrow.
And...
Uh...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We will finish the game.
And I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
Same time.
Starting same time tomorrow.
And...
We'll get through it.
Uh...
There will be less streams this week.
So I'm apologizing in advance.
And next week...
Basically for May, there will be a lot less streams.
Since I'm pretty busy.
But...
Uh...
Um...
Come June, I'll be...
I will be...
Less busy.
So things will go more back to normal then.
And...
Come July, things will be even more normal.
Since June has some events.
Such as...
Off Kai.
Mm-hmm.
So yeah.
Okie dokie.
Thank you guys!
For Devil May Cry!
And we'll finish...
Tomorrow on...
May 5th.
Devil May Cry...
Devil May 5th.
Yeah!
So...
I'm gonna go eat.
Thank you guys!
I'm so hungry.
Ocha minto!
Ocha minky!
Ocha minky minky!
Iitte rashai!
See you guys later!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye!